nous poursuivons l'examen euh pour avis
des missions budgétaires relevant de
notre commission avec l'examen de la
mission outre maire et je suis
particulièrement ravi de vous recevoir
Monsieur le Ministre pour la première
fois dans dans cette commission des lois
pour que vous nous présentiez les
grandes lignes de ce budget donc après
votre intervention on aura donc notre
rapporteur pour avis Johann Gillet qui
pourra intervenir puis un orateur par
groupe et ensuite les députés qui
souhaiter as poser une question pourrons
le faire pour une durée de 2
minutes après vos réponses nous
examinerons les amendements alors ils
sont fort nombreux cette année donc les
amendements pour les crédits et par
contre en votre absence comme le prévoit
monsieur le ministre le règlement
s'agissant des lois de finances alors
monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le
Président je suis très heureux de de
vous retrouver et est très heureux de
venir devant la commission des lois
pour cette audition dans le cadre du
budget des territoires ultraarin
alors je voudrais simplement retracer
très rapidement ce qui a été fait depuis
2017 et puis naturellement aborder avec
vous ce budget 2024 et j'aurai plaisir à
répondre à l'ensemble des interrogations
tout à l'heure ainsi que la défini le
président dans les règles telles que
vous les avez
établies si je souhaite refaire un focus
sur ce qui depuis 2017 c'est parce que
le temps long aussi permet d'apprécier
les efforts qu'on pu être à un moment
ou un autre fait en matière budgétaire
et cet effort budgétaire global pour l't
en utreemè il a progressé de
pratiquement de de 6 milliards d'euros
depuis 2017 en autorisation d'engagement
et de 7,4 milliards en crédit de
paiement je crois que ça mérite d'être
souligné en fait si on fait une
consolidation sur tous les ministères
concernés ce sont 120 milliards d'euros
que l'État a mobilisé en outreem depuis
pour la santé je rappelle rapidement la
rénovation d'hôpitaux aux Antill en
Guyane à Mayotte à la Réunion un plan de
92 millions notamment pour la prodution
du à la clord d'con aux Antilles pour
les infrastructures 740 millions d'euros
profit des collectivités pour améliorer
l'accès à l'eau c'est un sujet j'imagine
sur lesquel nous reviendrons la
livraison du premier tronçon de la
nouvelle route du littoral de la Réunion
ou le déploiement du Plan Séisme aux
Antilles pour conforter les bâtiments
publics les jeunes n'ont pas été oublié
la construction de lycées de collèges
d'écoles euh cé important pour 120
millions d'euros par an 120 millions
d'euros par an c'est 600 millions
d'euros et 130000 jeunes ultramarins qu'
été signataire d'un contrat
d'apprentissage d'une garantie jeune ou
d'un contrat d'engagement jeune pour
l'emploi un renforcement 2019 je le
rappelle les exonérations patronales
dites l'odéom qui a permis de diminuer
le nombre de chômeurs de de 40000 même
si le taux de chômage rest extrêmement
élevé de à trois fois supérieurs à celui
que l'on connaît dans l'Hexagone et bien
sûr le SMA qui n'a pas perdu de sa
vitalité bien au contraire puisqu'il y a
une nouvelles implantation vous le savez
à Ao et à Mayotte pour la formation 7
Pact ultramarin qui ont permis de
mobiliser 560 millions d'euros la
protection sociale 55000 logements
sociaux construits on sait qu'il y a
devant nous des dizaines de milieux de
logements à construire mais il n'était
pas inutile de rappeler cet effort déjà
qui avait été réalisé pour la sécurité
et services public j'imagine qu'on y
reviendra 1267 effectifs de force de
sécurité intérieure et 110 maisons
France service donc la notion de service
public n'a pas été oublié pour
accompagner les collectivités une
question qui m''est souvent posée lors
des déplacements la dacom la dacom a été
revalorisée de 150 millions d'euros
depuis 2016 et puis vous savez les
fameux quum qui sont les les contrats
qui permettent le redressement des
collectivités qui ont été lancés en 2021
connaissent un vrai succès il y avait
une ne9u signature en 2021 12 en 2022 et
puis le fond exceptionnel
d'investissement à hauteur de 110
millions d'euros alors nous arrivons au
budget 2024 je voudrais tout de suite
dire que il est en augmentation de 4,4 %
en autorisation d'engagement j'ai enlevé
naturellement l'inflation parce qu'en
fait c'est un budget en augmentation de
7 % mais comme il y a une inflation qui
est attendu à 26 le mieux était quand
même avec honnetteté de faire cette
soustraction et il est vrai comme l'a
dit le rapporteur Queen crédit de
paiement ce sera une augmentation de 2 %
mais vous pouvez dire que autant le
gouvernement euh ouvre les autorisations
d'Eng les crédits de paiement c'est pas
le gouvernement qui met d'ouvrage les
crédits de paiement ne dépendent
naturellement que des réalisations qui
sont faites dans chacun des territoire
alors ce budget 2024 d'abord il y a un
effort significatif sur le logement j'ai
dit tout à l'heure ils ont les choses
très clairement il y a un retard
considérable sur le logement nous
faisons un effort de 70 millions d'euros
notamment 50 millions au titre de ce
qu'on appelle la LBU cette ligne
budgétaire unique qui atteindra
pratiquement 300 millions d'euros en en
2024 mais on augmente également et c'est
une demande qui a été faite et je crois
été apprécié dans les déplacement que
j'ai pu faire sur les crédit d'impôt
dans la rénovation des logements sociaux
hors quartier politique de la ville
c'est une nouveauté donc pour un montant
de 20 millions d'euros donc ça permettra
d'aller plus loin de réhabilitation du
parc de logement privé d' locative
sociale également d'ailleurs un effort
au tire de des logement privé sur les
aides de l'ANA qui passe de 30 à 50 % et
donc ça c'est un élément déclencheur et
je rappelle d'ailleurs que les aides de
l' peuvent être abondés par les
collectivités donc ça permet je crois
d'apporter une bonne réponse à celles et
ceux qui en ont besoin pour l'accès à
l'eau bien sûr il y a le traitement en
urgence de Mayotte on y reviendra
probablement je vois que le député
camaradine est là 35 millions d'euros en
2023 mais un plan de 4 41 millions
d'euros sur les les quatre prochaines
années je n'oublie pas que même si c'est
les compétences des collectivités vous
avez pu voir que sur l'eau à Mayotte euh
nous sommes au rendez-vous après il nous
faudra que ce qui est écrit sur le
papier devient effectif nous éveillerons
ensemble je voudrais rappeler la semaine
dernière nous avons signé en Guadeloupe
le avec le syndicat le SME AEG un
contrat de 320 millions d'euros et c'est
la première fois qu'il y a une telle
mobilisation de la région qui met 80
millions le fond féire le Conseil
départemental qui met 20 millions
d'euros et l'État qui abond dans un
premier temps de 100 millions d'euros
donc cette question de l'eau d'ailleurs
on voit qu'elle se pose également en
guyan le président de la délégation est
là j'avais des notes ce matin qui me
confirment les propos qu'il avait pu
tenir lorsque j'ai rencontré les
parlementaires en mettant que ce sujet
de Lang guyan était un sujet qui donit
de plus en plus prignant et auquel nous
aurons à faire face ensemble sur les
sargas une question également qui est
très prignante dans les Antilles donc
nous augmentons les crédits de 1,4
million d'euros et puis je rappelle que
dans le casre du FEI il y a un règlement
qui est sorti le fond exceptionnel
d'investissement si nous avons mis les
priorités dans le FEI il reste pour
autant un élément souple et euh C fi
pourra le cas échéant à la demande des
élus intervenir sur cette question des
sgases sur le volet arèire des PCT des
solidarité on parle souvent de
solidarité vis-à-vis des différents
publics il y a un pack qui a été mis en
place de 50 millions d'euros d'ici 2027
qui se décline de trois façons 1 pour
les petitsdéjeunés et on approvisionné
10 millions d'euros 20 millions pour la
contractualisation avec les
collectivités pour la gratuité des
manuels scolaire je pense que dans
l'accès à l'éducation la gratuité du
manuel scolairire est un élément
important et puis million enfin pour des
mesures spécifiques parce que il y a des
familles pour lesquelles le prix du
repas à la cantine est trop élevé des
sujets lié à la médiation en santé la
réduction des bidonville la lutte contre
l'ilétrisme même sur la lutte contre
l'ilétrisme nous avons d'autres
programmes avec le ministère des utrem
notamment avec la Direction générale des
ultremes et la fameuse association
lancli sur la mobilité des ultramarins
je voudrais m'arrêter une seconde parce
qu'il y a un effort très particulier qui
est fait pour l'année 2024 puisque pour
la continuité territoriale les crédits
passent de 70 à 93 millions d'euros
c'est une augmentation de 23 millions
surtout avec deux choses nouvelles c'est
que le coent familial à partir duquel il
y a possibilité de bénéficier de cette
continuité territoriale a été relevé de
50 % je dis bien de 50 % il passe de
12000 € à 18000 € mais également les
publs ont été élargis pas simplement les
étudiants mais
également bien sûr les chômeurs les
sportifs de haut niveau dans un cas de
certains événements culturels on
pourrait également intervenir des
conditions dans lesquelles il y a une
situation sociale qui exige que la
solidarité s'applique nous le ferons
également et pour que cette mobilité
fonctionne également on ouvrira le cadre
d'emploi de l'agence la loi d'omme qui
qui s'occupe vous le savez de laadme qui
s'occupe de l'ensemble de la gestion de
ces déplacements puisque le cadre
d'emploi augmentera singulièrement de 13
donc de la LADOM pour atteindre 140
personnes 140 personnes pour s'occuper
des mobilités j'ai bien conscience que
cette question est revenue à plusieurs
reprises de l'augmentation tarifaire des
billet d'avion parce que il y a un vrai
sujet la notion de concurrence on les va
crapt dans les questions est
naturellement centrale mais nous
souhaitions par cet effort de 23 million
d'euros en plus hein c'est quand même
substantiel et l'élargissement des
publics être à la hauteur des enjeux le
dispositif cadre d'avenir je sais que
certains d'entre vous il sont très
attachés qui accompagnent l'formation et
le retour parce que c'est une souvent
disent c'est que euh partent dans le
dans l'Hexagone celles et ceux qui
veulent se former et ensuite reviennent
peu et donc là c'est cas d'avenir ce
dispositif sera étendu en Guadeloupe et
à Saint-Martin en 2023 et en Martinique
en 2024 et je sais que pour le
déploiement en Guyane et à Saint-Pier
mécllon un certain nombre de de
parlementaires il sont très attachés
sachez que je suis favorable et que nous
trouverons un aboutissement ensemble sur
la création d'emploi la création de
valeur le développement économique euh
là il y a donc le dispositif de l'odum
de d'exonération de de cotisation
sociale je rappelle qu'il avait été
lancé en 2019 il sera unchangé en 2024
et une évaluation a été lancée mais pour
autant ça reste ainsi et c'est du solide
sur lequel nous nous appuyons et en tout
cas si jamais il y a des modifications
ces modifications feront l'objet de
discussion au travers du cum lequel sium
vous savez a été validé 18 juillet vivra
tous les 3 mois le premier rendez-vous
je le dis devant la commission des lois
le premier rendez-vous aura lieu avec
l'ensemble des parlementaires et et des
patrons de collectivité et de
l'Association des Maires des territoires
concernés le 23 et 24 novembre prochain
c'est un engagement que nous avions pris
cet engagement nous allons le tenir sur
le SMA les services militaires adaptés
les crédits augmentent de 12 millionons
d'euros l'année prochaine je crois que
ce dispositif d'intégration est connu et
apporte beaucoup de de résultats très
positifs 80 % d'intégration des jeunes à
l'issue de ces formations donc
augmentation du du budget conséquente et
avec des études que nous faisons pour
étendre ce ce SMA sur d'autres
territoires il y a des demandes à
Saint-Martin qui sont récurrentes sur
les dépenses fiscales il y a
l'investissement productif le fameux
rafip donc c'est tout est prolongé
jusqu'en 2029 il y a trois niches
fiscales sur lesqueles il y a des
modifications qui sont apporté il y a eu
des rencontres sur ce sujet on a eu
échanges de courriers je rappelle que
les chauffeau solaire pour l'usage
professionnel seront protégés ils ne
seront pas en revanche protégés pour les
particuliers mais pour les particuliers
ils ont des dispositifs hautes comme
prime Renov pour les véhicules de
tourisme là encore des fiscalisation
sera possible pour les usages
professionnels quand les véhicules sont
indispensables naturellement pour
l'activité professionnelle et pour Lesur
de voiture j'ai été sensible à
l'argument et au questionnements aux
interrogations aux écrits que j'ai pu
recevoir et nous sommes en train de voir
en fonction des certaines catégories de
véhicules comment on pourrait apporter
une réponse en tout cas nous aurons une
réserve de précaution budgétaire et là
encore avec la profession nous nous
proposons de mettre en place un
dispositif concernant le tourisme tous
les tous les dispositifs qui étaient en
place fonctionnent à l'exclusion d'un
seul euh c'est les fameuses villas qui
éta qui étaient devenus des meublés de
tourisme sur lesquels on a pu voir qu'il
y avait quand même pas toujours l'usage
initial qui était isage souhaité euh
d'autant plus que si ces maisonsl sont
transformées en meublé alors qu'on a une
grave crive de logement on peut
s'interroger sur le fait que quand on
sait la difficulté les tensions qu'il y
a sur le foncier ça serait bien que l'
puisse trouver une solution pour autant
à la demande d'un certain nombre d'entre
vous nous regarderons les structures
dans lesquelles il y a dans le cadre de
de ces fameux meublés plusieurs
couchages qui derrière en fait il y a
une activité économique qui veut donc
dire un emploi et qui veut dire une
création de valeur donc nous sommes
ouverts à regarder les choses et nous le
ferons enfin sur le dévement économique
les les fameuses vanges les zones
franches qui sont élargis renforcés et
je crois qu'il fallait le souligner les
CCT tout le monde connaît les CCT dans
les territoires ultramarins qui
reviennent à notre contrat de plan état
région dans les territoires hexagonaux
et bien retenez simplement qu'ils
augmentent de 400 millions d'euros 400
millions d'euros je vous demande quand
même même si c'est vrai qu'il y a des
retards dans les territoir ultramarin
c'est vrai qu'on doit marquer encore
plus l'effort je pense que par rapport à
l'ensemble de ce qui se passe dans
l'Hexagone c'est un effort important
tous les mandats ont été donnés aux
mains des préfets l'ofb par exemple sur
l'eau est extrêmement mobilisé avec 120
millions d'euros en plus pour l'eau
l'assaainissement les transports le sont
également et l'éducation parce que à
Mayotte et en Guyane vous imaginez que
ce sont des efforts que l'on doit faire
porter les contrats de redressement et
presque terminé monsieur le Président
les Corum donc il connaissent un vrai
succès je disais tout à l'heure que 9uf
avaient été lancé en 2021 12 9 en 2022
pardon 12 cette année ça fait donc 21 il
y a 42 communes éligibles pour être
extrêmement précis donc sur les 42
communes 50 % s voit proposer ce cororum
je crois que c'est du gagnant gagnant
gagnant pour les collectivités don je
rappelle que le dernier signé la semaine
dernière en Guadeloupe c'est 2100000 €
qui sont proposés à la collectivité en
échange naturellement une évolution de
sa gestion pour rentrer plus dans ces
critères que nous demandons donc cet
effort nous le poursuivrons et un nouvel
appel à candidature sera lancé pour 2024
2026 enfin sur l'investissement des
collectivités le FEI que vous connaissez
le fond exceptionnel d'investissement
qui é 110 millions d'euros sera préservé
et probablement augmenté lorsque nous
aurons finalisé ce budget sur les
constructions scolaires en dehors de ce
qui se passe dans les CCT il y a un
effort de 120 millions pour la Guyane et
Mayotte et la Nouvelle-Calédonie il y a
toujours vous savez que
Nouvelle-Calédonie il y a une
reconversion de l'économie polynésienne
qui est financée à hauteur de 60 million
d'euros par an enfin un dernier mot
c'est l'ingéerie l'ingénierie donc vous
savez expertise FRANCE a été créée on a
un vrai souci d'expertise d'ailleurs je
vous proposerai et si le le président de
la Commission on est d'accord viendrait
devant vous pour une séance de travail
pour pour voir comment on peut améliorer
ce niveau d'expertise à la main
naturellement des territoires de façon à
ce que ça permett d'avoir les
compétences requises trop souvent on
prend du retard dans les opérations je
déplore qui dit retard dit surcout des
opérations qui dit surcout quelquefois
non réalisation de ces opérations et
c'est bien
dommageable mais c'est ainsi je v
prendre un seul exemple heureusement le
le centre hospitalier de de Guadeloupe
va va se terminé on a démarré à 380
millions on finit à 650 millions on aura
un établissement absolument superbe je
n'oublie pas tous les moyens que nous
avons mis en supplément sur la sécurité
mais dans les questions j'imagine
qu'elles seront posées j'aurai la
possibilité de vous dire territoire par
territoire quels ont été les engagements
que nous avons pris dans le temps et
j'ai un tableau qui sera à votre
disposition si vous le souhaitez
d'évolution des forces de sécurité que
ce soit les gendarmes que ce soit les
policiers sur les 5 années parce que
l'effort il se mesure dans la durée se
mesure pas en une seule fois et bien sûr
sur les questions liées à la justice au
programme péniten je tiens à vos
disposition si vous le souhaitez voilà
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés l'intervention liminire que
je souhaitais faire merci
beaucoup voilà merci merci monsieur le
ministre sans plus tarder donc la parole
à notre rapporteur pour avis de la des
crédits de la mission outreem monsieur
Johann Gillet merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues le gouvernement se félicite
d'une augmentation des crédits pour
l'outre maire une hausse pourtant bien
timide les crédits attadront 2,7
milliards d'euros en 2024 soit une
hausse de 4,5 % par rapport à l'an
dernier mais il faut néanmoins souligner
qu'en prenant en compte les prévisions
d'inflation vous l'avez dit la hausse
des crédits missions autromè apparaît en
fait inférieure à 2 %. alors qu'il
aurait nécessité une rupture ce budget
s'inscrit dans la continuité des
exercices précédents il est à ce titre
largement insuffisant et n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux car si les Français
d'outremer sont confrontés au mêmes
problèm que les Français de l'hexagone
et à bien d'autres plus spécifiques
l'éloignement fait que ces problèmes
sont souvent plus marqué et moins bien
traité par les pouvoirs publics tout
d'abord et c'est le thème de mon rapport
une immigration hors de contrôle qui
déstabilise les sociétés et aggrave la
délinquence et la criminalité notamment
en Guyane et à Mayotte en lien avec le
sujet que je viens de citer une
insécurité galopante faute d'une volonté
politique et de moyens notamment en
matière pénale un pouvoir d'achat
insuffisant inférieur à celui de la
métropole ce qui constitue une injustice
aggravée par la vie chère un chômage de
masse conséquence d'une absence de
politique économique adaptée aux
spécificités ultramarines des
infrastructures insuffisantes des routes
et des transports lacunaires des
logements insalubres des écoles et des
hôpitaux sous pression sans parler de
l'accès défaillant à l'eau potable au
regard de tous ces enjeux brûlants le
budget des outres-mères dans le projet
de loi de finance pour 2024 illustre le
cruel manque d'ambition et de vision du
gouvernement pour ces territoirees pire
il reflète un certain mépris monsieur le
ministre la hausse timide des crédits
qui concerne pour l'essentiel les
dispositifs d'exonération de charg
social est très insuffisante des actions
importantes comme le financement de
l'économie l'aménagement du territoire
ou encore l'aide à l'insertion
professionnelle ne connaissent aucune
augmentation ce qui comptetenu de
l'inflation constitue en réalité une
baisse importante des crédits en euro
courant cette année soucieux de dépasser
le strict p mare de la mission outr-emè
j'ai choisi donc de consacrer la
deuxième partie de mon rapport à
l'immigration massive dans les outrmers
ce sujet reste malheureusement au cœur
de l'actualité avec celui de
l'insécurité auquel il est bien sûr lié
vol avec violence agression scène de
Guera urbaine sont trop souvent le lot
de nos compatriotes ultramarins et les
statistiques tenues par l'administration
judiciaire et pénitentiaire soulignent
sans équivoque la surreprésentation des
étrangers dans la délinquence et la
criminalité outre mer au-delà des coûts
de pro projecteurs médiatique les
chiffres sont parlants les faits de coût
et blessures volontairees par exemple
qui sont de 4,5 pour 1000 personnes en
France hexagonale atteignent 7,4 % 7,4
pardon en moyenne outreem et même 8,4 en
Guadeloupe et 9,8 en guyan les
conséquences sont directes et
quotidiennes pour plus de 2 millions de
nos compatriotes comment vivre
normalement lorsqu'on craint de se faire
agresser ou d'être victime d'un vol
violent comment aller travailler si les
sont bloqué comment assurer une
éducation à ses enfants si sa voiture le
car scolaire ou l'École ont été incendié
sans compter les conséquence de
l'insécurité pour le tourisme et
l'attractivité économique de ces
territoirees parmi les principaux
facteurs de l'insécurité on trouve
l'incapacité du gouvernement à contrôler
nos frontières outreem à cause
d'effectifs insuffisants dans la police
aux frontières et de matériels qui ne
sont pas à la hauteur de la veue même
des forces de l'ordre notamment en
Guyane qu'il s'agisse des drones des
radars des bateaux intercepteurs
notamment dans un environnement
géographique souvent instable et
économiquement défavorisé cette porosité
des frontières expose les territoires à
une immigration clandestine qui apporte
tout types de trafic armes stupéfiant
pardon et même migrants s'en suivent des
règlements de compte des infractions
violentes des cûts de sang sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants ou d'alcool à
proximité d'armes ces territoires
connaissent de façon générale une
situation socio-économique plus dégradée
que le reste de la France avec des
nuances locales le chômage les
difficultés familiales et la pauvreté
entretiennent certes l'insécurité mais
souvent le point de départ est la
présence de personnes en situation
irrégulière habitué à une violence
banalisée et au trafic ou infraction
lucratif la situation sécuritaire à
Mayotte submergé par une immigration
incontrôlable en prvalence des Comores
l'illustre suffisamment les timides
Hauses d'effectifs des forces de l'ordre
ne sont pas suffisantes sans le choc de
moyens que j'évoqué la situation
deviendra hors de contrôle ô coopération
diplomatique réponse judiciaire
développement socio-économique moyens de
surveillance et de contrôle aux
frontières présence de forces de l'ordre
tous ces axes doivent être renforcés et
les 10 propositions que je formule dans
mon rapport sont à la disposition de
toutes les bonnes volontés rien ne sera
possible sans une volonté politique
forte bien sûr les conséquences de
l'immigration ne se limitent pas à
l'insécurité comme le montre mon rapport
elle concerne aussi l'école en mettant
sous pression le bâti scolaire qui ne
peut pas suivre la cadence 20 nouvelles
classes sont ainsi par exemple
construites chaque année à Saint-Laurent
du Maroni l'hôpital avec des maternités
sous pression et des soins urgents qui
ne seront jamais payés l'économie
paralysée par une économie clandestine
d'ampleur qui plombe les recettes
fiscales comme le développement de ces
territoires le logement avec les sorts
de bidonville en Guyanne et à Mayotte
notamment en un mot les conséquen
sociales de l'immigration bouleverse à
la fois les services publics et les
sociétés d'outremè lors des auditions
que j'ai mené les élus et les
représentants des syndicats de police
ont dit leur laassitude d'être sans
cesse entendu par les parlementaires
sans que rien ne change à ce rythme la
situation deviendra selon eux
incontrôlable dans 10 ans en Guyane et à
Mayotte collègu allez-vous vous
contenter de refléter de refiler pardon
le bébé aux élus suivants en détournant
le regard pendant encore 4 ans Monsieur
le Ministre allez-vous vous aussi comme
vos prédécesseurs laisser la situation
pourrir plus que de la lcitude nos élus
nos professeurs nos médecins nos forces
de l'ordre et en général les habitants
de ces territoires sont en colère et ils
ont raison ils doivent non seulement
être écoutés mais être aussi entendus
pour que nos compatriotes ultramarins
connaissent enfin le cadre de vie auquel
ils ont le droit je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur je
on va passer la parole au groupe pour le
groupe Renaissance monsieur
Vilte merci mon 4 minutes 4 minutes très
bien bien j'essaierai de ne pas
abuser je vais remettre mon micro
écoutez j'ai bien écouter ce que vient
de dire le rapporteur et objectivement
on peut toujours trouver que un budget
n'est pas bon parce que par définition
il ne doit pas être bon dès lors qu'on
est dans l'opposition puis on peut aussi
mesurer un peu ce que ce qui s'est passé
dans les années précédentes et l'état
des chosesquel le moment on est arrivé
et moi je remarque quand même que il y a
deux éléments de contexte qu'il faut
avoir en tête le premier élément c'est
que je me souviens je crois l'avoir déjà
cité lors de d'une précédente discussion
budgétaire K qui est alors ministre et
des outres mes et qui est une femme
honnête comme on dit quelqu'un qui est
sincère dans ses propos je le dis en
face d'un collègue du groupe socialiste
se réjouissait et disait sa fierté il y
a quelques années de ça je crois que
c'éta en 2016 que le budget l'outremè
soit à 2 milliards d'euros il est
maintenant à 3 milliards d'euros on ne
peut pas dire qu'il y ait derrière cela
un désengagement de l'État qu' cela un
désintérêt du gouvernement par rapport à
un domaine dans lequel il a beaucoup
investi quand on prend le les crédits
transversaux c'estàd il y a les budgets
de de l'autre maire autour des deux
missions que nous connaissons bien avec
une augmentation de 5 % et de 7 % je
revi je reviendrai peut-être tout à
l'heure là-dessus rapidement mais quand
on regarde les crédits transversaux
c'est dire tout ce que fait l'état en
dehors de ces budgets fléchés on
remarque aussi qu'on est passé d'à peu
près 17 milliards d'euros à aujourd'hui
plus de 22 quasiment 23 donc tout ça
pour dire que je crois que ce
gouvernement que cette majorité ne veut
pas être taxé d'avoir négligé les autres
maires maintenant est-ce que cela veut
dire que nous sommes dans une situation
qui est satisfaisante évidemment non
nous le savons bien ce sont ce sont des
des décennies de sous-investissement de
l'État par rapport à ces territoires
qu'il faut aujourd'hui compenser c'est
le rôle des contrats de convergence et
de transition
qui progresse puisque de la génération
précédente à maintenant nous passons de
1,8 milliards d'euros à 2,4 milliards
d'euros mais nous savons bien aussi
qu'il faudra du temps pour pouvoir
opérer ce cette cette convergence et ce
rattrapage parce que simplement on le
voit bien dans la consommation des
crédits il y a un moment donné aussi où
les territoires doivent aussi prendre
avoir leur rythme pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir les opérer ses actions je
remarque il y a des choses qui sont tout
à fait considérables je crois en
particulier au à l'action qui est menée
sur le logement avec un niveau inédit de
pr de 300 millions d'euros consacrés à
la fameuse LBU qui permet d'actionner
sur le logement mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on le fait maintenant pourquoi au
bout de 6 ans quelque part de cette
majorité c'est c'est cette année 2024
qui verra ce niveau de 300 millions en
progression près de 50 millions
arrivriver sur sur sur le créit du
lement mais simplement parce que ça fait
2 ans que grâce à l'ingénierriie que
nous mettons en place et je me souviens
avoir entendu quelques minutes le
ministre et autres ma en parl c'est
grâce à inéérique nous pouvons
maintenant effectivement consommer ces
crédits et faire en sorte qu'il a une
action qui qui soit efficace même si
encore une fois elle ne gomme pas des
années de d'inertie sur sur le sur le
logement donc tout ça pour dire que je
crois que ces crédits mérit d'être
améliorés sont toujours à discuter il
faut toujours une rigueur et une
exigence par rapport à leur mise en
œuvre je crois que nous pouvons
améliorer au travers du débat budgétaire
je souhaite peut-être pas forcément dans
le cadre de ce qui s'était passé lors de
la commission de de des finances que
nous puissions avoir un débat un débat
qui soit constructif en la matière et
qui permette effectivement de de
effectivement de faireer les choses
enentre autre parce que nous avons des
urgences je pense en particulier à l'eau
et puis je vous parler de deux éléments
de contexte deuxième c'est que il y a
quelque chose de très fort qui a été
fait vous ne'en voudrez pas monsieur le
ministre de rendre hommage à votre
prédécesseur c'est celui du sium du
comité interministériel des outremères
qui a perd de définir 72 mesures
validées par la par la première ministre
et fait avec les collectivités locales
avec les acteurs ultr-amarins qui doont
nous permettre de franchir un cap et je
terminerai dans les 9 secondes qui me
reste par vous poser des questions je
suis surpris quand même par la mesure de
la première partie du budget sur la
fiscalité où vous revenez sur
d'exonération on voit bien sur les
chauff c'est quelque chose de
souhaitable mais sur les autres domaines
c'est moins sûr et je voudrais vous
poser une question aussi sur le fr un
rapport nous avait été promis pour
savoir si les mesures étaient efficaces
sachant qu' neétaent pas mais maintenant
on ne veut pas nous resservir à chaque
fois les mêmes réponses sommes nous
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci pour le
rassemblement national j'ai comme
inscrit Florence Goul oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur présidentsieur
ministre délégué monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
délégué nous ne pouvons nous satisfaire
de votre présentation nm opération de
communication le groupe rassemblement
national pour lequel je m'exprime
rejoint les préconisations de notre
rapporteur Johann Gillet dont je salue
la qualité du travail fourni son avis
budgétaire et qui pointe les
conséquences sociales de l'immigration
incontrôlée dans la France des outr m
alors certes le gouvernement propose une
augmentation du budget pour l'outre
maire c'est déjà ça mais c'est tellement
ement peu car cette hausse ne masquera
pas la situation catastrophique dans
laquelle se trouvve nos territoires
ultramarins depuis bien trop longtemps
et le pire ayant été atteint depuis 2017
les problèmes s'étant plus que jamais
aggravés criminalité croissante
immigration massive pouvoir d'achat en
chute libre chômage endémique jeunesse
sous le seuil de pauvreté agriculture en
berne pénurie d'eau potable dans trois
départements français au 21e siècle
clord desconnes sargace octroi de mer
anachronique et je ne parlerai pas ici
des aspects concurrentiels de pays-tiers
au détriment de nos compatriotes
ultramarins qui subissent un coût de la
vie chè comment pouvons-nous accepter de
teles écart le panier de la ménagère de
l'outrema esttant près de 20 % supérieur
à celui de l'Hexagone comment
pouvons-nous accepter quand le
gouvernement vente le plein emploi
l'industrie verte à tous les étages
comporte atteinte à la dignité de nos
compatriotes ultramarins en leur
manquant de respect en les prenant pour
des citoyens arriérés en ne leur
présentant comme solution au manque
d'eau que de leur apprendre à la faire
bouillir dans une casserole comment
pouvons-nous accepter que pour des
raisons partisannes de pures tactiques
politiciennes vos représentants au
Parlement européen et refuser l'ajout de
ce sujet pourtant vital à l'ordre du
jour des débats et qu'il n'it ensuite
pas voté un amendement budgétaire du
rassemblement national sur l'aide à
l'accès à l'eau courante et potable dans
ces régions vous ne créez pas les
conditions d'un retour à l'ordre
républicain dans nos département et
territoires ultramarins notamment à
Mayotte en Guyane et aux Antilles exposé
à la criminalité à la violence au
développement du trafic de stupéfiants
et aux effets délétaires et ruineux
d'une immigration qui pèse en premier
lieu sur le quotidien de nos
compatriotes ultramarin comme notre
rapporteur le soulligne rappelons qu'à
Mayotte plus d'un tiers de la population
est étrangère d'aut au moins la moitié
en situation illégale et que l'opération
wambouchou censé mettre un terme au
chaos migratoire de Mayot n'a fait que
l'accentuer depuis le retrait des forces
de l'ordre et n'aura été qu'un fiasco
retentissant les territoires ultramarins
attendent bien plus que des a justement
de réorganisation du sium des Assises
des États généraux et autres livres
bleus et blancs de ces dernières années
les Français des outremur des outrmèes
veulent savoir où et comment le
gouvernement les emmène à court moyen et
long terme la France des outrmèes a
besoin d'un électrochoc d'une vraie
politique de croissance et d'autonomie
économique nous en sommes
malheureusement bien loin nos
amendements répondent en premier lieu
aux urgenence vital et tout ce qui
favorisera les infrastructures en
particulier pour l'eau mais nous nous
abstiendrons sur ce budget qui manque
autant de clairvoyance que d'ambition et
qui n'apporte aucune réelle solution à
tous ces sujets endémiques qui
pénalisent nos compatriotes ultramarins
pourtant citoyens à part entière de
notre nation et non entièrement à à part
et qui à ce titre mérite tout notre
respect et notre considération je vous
remercie merci pour la France insoumise
c'est Monsieur
nillor par pour 4 minutes 4 minutes
monsieur le Président j'ai fait 8000 km
je suis arrivé aujourd'hui alors si je
dépasse comme mon collègue vilt de
quelques secondes je serai je serai
tolérant je compte sur votre indig d'un
point de vue comptable cette mission
outre ma affiche fiement une
augmentation que vous avez monsieur le
ministre corrigé je salue cette
honnêteté euh donc 4 pour 4 4 % en
autorisation d'engagement et 2 % en
crédit de
paiement bravo mais pourtant je dire que
à l'image de ce budget l'état manque
cruellement
d'ambition pour nos territoires un
exemple particulièrement éloquant de ces
chiffres en trompeleuil se trouve dans
le programme 123 conditions de vra
notamment sur l'axe 1 consacré au
logement la LBU ligne budgétaire unique
augmente certes elle est désormais de
291 millions
d'euros mais lorsque l'on sait que le
montant de la LBU était de
289 million d'euros en 2010 soit il y a
14 ans il y a de quoi tempérer l'
faie alors même que l'inflation est
galopante alors même que 13 % du parc de
logement est insalubre que 600000
personnes sont mal logées que les plans
logement outre mer euh n'ont jamais
atteint le objectif et que
100000 logements constituent le déficit
en logements sociaux et que
d'innombrables
ne sont pas aux normes
sismiques ce que nous voulons c'est un
véritable plan pluriannuel mais avec des
moyens financiers une stratégie à la
hauteur des enjeux pour en finir avec
cette pénurie de logements sociaux ce
que nous voulons ce sont des dispositifs
spécifiques innovants prenant en compte
par exemple les coûts du désamientage
des logements individuels et des autres
bâtiments publics écoles crèches et
cetera ce que nous voulons c'est la
création d'une d'un véritable
observatoire du logement à même de
fournir des données fiables et d'évaluer
objectivement les politiques publiques
passé et futur j'attire d'ors et déjà je
de manière un peu opportune opportuniste
je l'avoue votre attention sur la
prochaine niche de notre parti de notre
groupe où euh je présenterai j'aurai
l'honneur de présenter une proposition
de résolution sur la création d'une
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
la gestion par l'état des risques
majeurs dans les oututremèes et je je je
comprendrai mal que votre majorité
n'accompagne pas cette initiative
s'agissant maintenant du programme 138
emploi auè faut-il encore rappeler que
les taux de chômage atteindent jusqu'à
30 % dans les outromères pour les jeunes
de 19 à 29 ans de 15 à 29 ans
il est deux fois supérieur à l'Hexagone
et face à ce fléo qui accélère le départ
massif des jeunes sans perspective
d'épanouissement au pays il importe
d'adopter un certain nombre de mesures
courageuses il est vrai que des
décennies de politique bumidomienne puis
laadomienne mise en œuvre par les
gouvernements successifs ont favorisé
une saigné démographique sans précédent
en vulgarisant l'idée que pour trouver
un emploi chez nous il suffisait de
traverser non pas la rue mais l'océan
Atlantique et pour renir ces jeunes nous
avons besoin d'entreprises de production
notamment qui soi réellement aidé et
accompagné et à ce propos monsieur le
ministre comptez-vous enfin répondre
favorablement à la demande
urgente de d'augmentation de la dotation
RSA régime spécifique
d'approvisionnement qui émane des
producteurs industriels de N territoire
parce que la sousdotation en la matière
est un facteur d'augmentation de viechè
de perte de compétitivité des
productions locales et de perte d'emploi
alors dans un contexte de chômage
endémique nos filières de production ne
comprennent pas aujourd'hui ce qui
semble être un revirement de l'État
puisque le président de la République
s'était engagé fermement à compenser le
montant global de 8 millions d'euros
pour Monsieur il va falloir conclure
j'ai j'ai été tolérant de 30 secondes je
je
en une phrase je conclus en une phrase
en disant que ce que nous voulons ce que
nous attendons c'est une vision
véritablement à long terme qui nous
permettent d'ancrer profondément les
conditions de développement économique
et social dans nos territoirees je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe les
républicains Mansour camardine pour 4
minutes de tolérance là aussi on essaie
de pas déborder monsieur le Président
pouvait même me tolerurer uniquement
pour intervenir pour 33 minutes il y
aura aucune difficulté parce que en ce
qui me concerne les choses sont
relativement simples monsieur le
ministre je note avec beaucoup d'intérêt
que vous vous battez pour que les choses
aillent malheureusement le budget on le
retournera sur dans tous les sens je
crois que la réponse n'y est pas a déjà
d'ailleurs la mission a été complètement
euh modifié à en commission des à la
commission des finances et donc la
question que nous nous posons certes
vous dites nous faisons beaucoup de
choses nous faisons des écoles nous
faisons des logements sociaux s'agissant
de Mayotte il y a une véritable
distorsion entre les priorités de l'État
et les priorités des maorés les
priorités des maorés aujourd'hui
monsieurés monsieur le ministre ne sont
pas dans les contions de logement
sociaux et dans les écoles parce que ce
sont des aimant à l'attraction à
l'immigration clandestine ce que nous
voulons et que vous n'avez vous avez
refusé monsieur le Président de de la
commission le sait lorsque nous avons
proposé euh une PPL pour tenir compte
des priorités des Maoris vous les avez
rejeté ce que nous voulons nous ce n'est
pas dans cette directionlà ce que nous
voulons ce qu'on mettre les routes
nationales qui sont de votre
compétenence l'université qui est de
votre compétence la le la piste longue
qui est de votre compéten euh ainsi de
suite les aménagements les structurant
pour le territoire et qui permettent au
Moré de ce qui nous ce que nous
souhaitons c'est qu'effectivement vous
luttiez efficacement contre les contre
l'immigration CLAND tout à l'heure le
collègue vil disait une chose Guillaume
je suis totalement d'accord avec vous
quand vous dites que nous assistons à
des décennies de sous-investissements
notre maire qu'il faut rattraper 40 % de
chômage à Mayotte 40 % pas
d'assainissement des EAU usées euh alors
que c'est une obligation de l'État j'ai
le sentiment que nous vivons dans un
certain dans une espèce dans une espèce
de cynisme on se dit on est prêt à payer
des amendes à la comment à la Commission
européenne mais ne pas faire les
investissements à mayott c'est ça la
réalité en tout cas c'est comme ça comm
donc c'est ce c'est dans cette
direction-là actuellement dans la
politique de lutte contre l'immigration
et je veux saluer l'effort qui est fait
moi je suis toujours reconnaissant quand
les choses sont faites et qui euh qui
est fait même si nous devons encore
aller plus loin je veux simplement dire
qu'à travers cette au au nom de cette
prétendu lutte contre l'immigration on a
viré tous les mains de le de leur lagon
les mais n'ont plus le droit d'aller
dans le lagon on leur dit que vous avez
des bateaux qui ne sont pas au norme
mais on fait rien pour le les aider à
avoir des bateau pour aller au N alors
oui on peut dire qu'il y a des choses
qui se font mais je suis moi en ce que
me concerne je considère que
effectivement le compte le compte n'y
est pas voyez-vous monsieur le Président
je souhaite que sur tous ces sujets- là
sur le ce que doit être le périmètre du
CCT parce que vous avez financé vous
nous parlez de CCT monsieur le ministre
mais quand on lit le budget votre projet
de budget on rencontre pas les
financements des CCCT à moins que je ne
sache pas lire un budget ça fait 40 ans
quee je je suis dans le métier on les
rencontre pas et donc je ne sais pas
comment vous allez financer C CCT sauf à
faire du pas tout à l'heure vous dis
disz monsieur le ministre dans l'eau
nous mettons 411 millions à Mayot je
vous rappelle simplement que les 411
millions ont été déjà prévus en 2017
combien combien ont été ont été
mobilisés alors on viendra vous dire
vous expliquez que ce sont les élus non
d'ailleurs il y a des articles de des
des grandes des grandes des grands
quotidiens nationaux qui vous le disent
la responsabilité de l'État vient
jusqu'au coup parce que on a on a certes
c'est une compétence de l'État certes
c'est une compétence de des Collectiv
mais quand on met pas les moyens quand
on refuse quand le préfet ferme les
robinets délibérément pour assfer les
populations et je pèse mes mots devant
cette commission je crois que c'est tout
ça ce sentiment de rejet à chaque fois
quand il s'agit de maillotes ça coûte
cher on peut regarder dans la oui
monsieur monsieur le ministre quand je
regarde la la la loi égalité réelle je
vous ai encore écrit cet après-midi la
loi égalité réelle qu'est-ce qu'il vous
dit il faut des critère de con de
convergence
pour pour réaliser l'égalité réelle à
mayottte on l'a exclu du CT quand je
regarde tout sur dans T ces directions
là Monsieur monsieur le Président je
finis je crois que les comptes tels
qu'elles sont présentés aujourd'hui je
sais que vous faites vous faites
l'effort pour nous convaincre de d'aller
dans votre direction je souhaite
vraiment le faire mais ça sera en
fonction des amendements qui seront
débattus tout à l'heure mes chers
collègues ne profitez pas de mon laxisme
apparent pour déborder j'ai voilà je je
suis tolérant parce que je sais que pour
Monsieur Nilor et pour monsieur
camardine et pour maintenant monsieur
Fran Fran gums vous ces budgets vous
tiennent à cœur mais essayez de rester
dans un délai raisonnable donc la parole
est pour le groupe démocrate à Fran
Franz
gums merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre toutes mes
salutations et je remercie cette
commission cette prestigieuse commission
de me recevoir cet
après-midi le le Budet 2024 pour les
territoires d'outrem et sa méthode
d'élaboration traduit me semble-t-il la
volonté du ministre de s'engager sinon
dans une certaine construction au moins
dans un dialogue avec les représentants
des territoires il prend en compte
certaines propositions issues du sium
par exemple et se veut en cohérence avec
les politiques menées par les autres
ministère je vais passer sur les
chiffres qui ont été rappelés par le
ministre et par le rapporteur euh pour
me contenter de quelques commentaires
plutôt
qualitatifs ce budget ne répond sûrement
pas à tous les besoins de rattrapage
économique de nos territoires lointains
mais force de constater que des efforts
significatifs sont faits en particulier
à travers le ciblage des situations les
plus en tension à travers une meilleure
prise en compte des réalités actuelles
de terrain et à travers l'affichage de
certaines
priorités monsieur le ministre vous R
entré d'une visite officielle en
Guadeloupe et ainsi que dans ma
circonscription de saint-bartelemi et
Saint-Martin vous avez fait des annonces
sur nombre de sujets en particulier face
à l'émoi provoqué par l'amendement dit
amendement cas9 vous avez cherché à
rassurer les professionnels du tourisme
quant au devenir des dispositifs de
défiscalisation en particulier sur les
véhicules de tourisme et sur les meublés
de tourisme avec la confirmation si j'ai
bien compris que les petites structures
consacrées exclusivement au tourisme
continueront à être
éligible je choisis de faire confiance à
la parole ministérielle sur ces sujets
de même que sur le sujet de
l'introduction d'Action Logement à
Saint-Martin le quotidien des
ultramarins est marqué par une vie chère
structurelle il est vrai dur contraintes
lié à leur situation géopolitique mais
aussi au choix de modèle de
développementc omique subi par ces
territoire je me réjouis de la priorité
donnée au mieux se loger à travers
l'accélération en matière de
construction de réhabilitation du parc
de logement privé locatif social ainsi
que la lutte contre l'habitat insalubre
indigne le besoin de mobilité des
ultrarin est également prise en compte
pour venir en hexagone mais surtout et
aussi pour le retour sur les territoires
c'est ainsi que le dispositif cadre
d'avenir est désormais étendu en
Guadeloupe et à Saint-Martin en 2023 il
la vocation à s'étendre aux autres
territoires et j'en suis heureux il
manque maintenant monsieur le ministre à
prendre en compte les déplacements entre
les territoires de même bassin pour
raison de formation ou pour le
développement de rencontres
sportives la contribution au
développement économique ainsi que la
création d'emploi est une préoccupation
de tous les instants dans nos
territoire les dispositifs d'exonération
des cotisations sociales spécifi aux
outremèes sont maintenus mais feront
l'objet d'une réévaluation il sera
nécessaire monsieur le ministre
d'aboutir à des évolutions juste et
justifié pour terminer je retiens que
l'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales territoriales reste une
mesure forte de ce budget qui se décline
en plusieurs dispositifs parmi lesquels
l'ingénierie dont vous avez parlé
nécessaire à la réalisation des projets
structurant la pérénisation du
dispositif cor Corum et la progression
des budgets des contrats de convergence
et du FEI ce budget donne un signal
positif pour cet exercice mais nos
territoires ont besoin de plus de
planification sur un temps plus long en
matière d'infrastructure en matière
d'économie et même en matière
d'évolution de nos relations nationales
et régionales en tout état de C je me
réjoui de l'évolution globale des
crédits et vous ne serez pas étonné que
mon groupe soutiendra euh vos
propositions j'attends cependant
l'engagement du gouvernement sur les
suites qui seront données aux mesures du
comité interministériel des outrè je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
vous profitez tous vous en profitez
tous pour le groupe socialiste monsieur
Gérard
leul merci chers collègue monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues tout d'abord merci de
m'accueillir au sein de votre commission
et je n'abuserai pas président du temps
que vous m'accordez donc je veux
aujourd'hui par cette intervention à la
fois rendre hommage à mes quatre collègu
ultramarin du groupe socialiste
apparenté Christian Baptiste Ellie
califer Johnny hajard et Philippe naayer
qui ont largement travailler à renforcer
les crédits alloués à la mission outrem
et également monsieur le ministre vous
questionner sur la suite que vous
entendez donner à ce vote dans le cadre
du projet de loi de financeces mercredi
25 octobre dernier le groupe socialiste
est apparenté avec d'autres a permis
d'adopter
735,7 millions de crédits
supplémentaires en faveur des
territoires ultramarins pour lutter
contre la vi chair nous avons fait voter
des crédits supplémentaires afin de
majorer les prestations sociales légales
versé autre m et pour répondre à la
problématique de la hausse des coût de
d'énergie nous avons également poussé
pour des moyens supplémentaires afin de
lutter contre des situations de monopole
ou d'oligopole qui génèent des super
profit au détriment des populations pour
la mobilité des ultramarins nous avons
fait voter 500 million d'euros afin de
porter les dépenses de l'État en matière
de continuité territoriale pour des
habitants d'utr m au même niveau les
mettant au même niveau que la Corse
aujourd'hui ces dépenses sont de 257 €
par habitant en Corse contre 16 € par
habitant ultramarin pour lutter contre
les effets du changement climatique nous
avons fait voter le renforcement du fond
de secours qui permet au territoire
ultramarin de faire face aux alléas
naturel et adopter un plan de rattrapage
des infrastructures indispensables au
territoire ultramarin au assaainissement
déchets voiri que vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure monsieur le ministre pour
préserver la santé publique et la
biodiversité nous avons fait voter 50
millions supplémentaires pour les
actions de prévention et de dépollution
au clord d'conne ainsi que des moyens
budgétaires pour assurer le ramassage de
des Sargasses au large de la Martinique
et de la Guadeloupe tous ces amendements
ont fait l'objet d'un chiffrage
raisonnable sur la base de constat
établis dans le cadre du rapport
budgétaire ou de la commission d'enquête
sur la vie cher rapportée par notre
collègue Johnny hajard donc ma question
est simple allez-vous entendre le besoin
de crédit supplémentaire défendu par nos
collègues ultramarins la plupart des
territoires ultramarins connaissent un
enclavement régional économique et
politique y compris en dehors de
l'insularité comme en Guyane où les
relations avec les voisins sont très
faibles trop faibles bien évidemment
territoires qui connaissent des
spécificités locales et des besoins de
financement particuliers plusieurs
orateurs tout à l'heure ont rappelé le
nécessaire besoins de rattrapage alors
Monsieur le Ministre allez-vous entendre
nos collègues et retenir leurs
amendements on totalité ou en partie ou
allez-vous une nouvelle fois tout
balayer au moment de l'utilisation du
493 je vous remercie merci Monsieur le
seul pour le groupe horizon et apparenté
Marie Agnès poussier vinback vinceb VB
tu AR
jamais depuis le début à chaque fois je
me PL c'est pas grave vous êtes pas le
premier je vous rassure monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur chers chers collègues pour
2024 les moyens de la mission s'élèvent
à 200 milliard en autorisation
d'engagement et 200 milillard 6 en
crédit de paiement à périmètres constant
soit des hausses substantielles par
rapport à 2023 nous saluons cette
augmentation des moyens mis au service
des territoires ultramarins et je me
réjouis que certains d'entre vous l'
également indiqué avec un programme
entier consacré à l'emploi en outremè le
travail occupe une place centrale dans
cette mission la place qu'il doit y
avoir 1ard85 millions d'euros
d'autorisation d'engagement et de crédit
de paiement sont consacré au
renforcement de la compétitivité des
entreprises et à la qualification
professionnelle des actifs ultramarins
notamment des jeunes pour qui ça déjà
été rappelé le taux de chômage est
malheureusement encore deux à trois fois
plus élevé que dans l'Hexagone la
qualification professionnel est un enjeu
majeur pour l'emploi nous regrettons à
ce titre pardon chers collègues voisins
à ce titre que l'adoption de 94
amendements commission des finances
puisque vous avez revendiqué tout à
l'heure monsieur le sol être à l'origine
d'un très grand nombre d'amendements euh
en commission des finances donc est
conduit à vider intégralement les
crédits de ce programme au profit du
programme non moins important des
conditions de vie en outreem face à la
crise que connaît le secteur le logement
est l'une des priorités qui ressort de
ce budget avec une impulsion
significative donné en matière de
construction de logement sociaux de
réhabilitation et d'adaptation au
vieillissement du parc de logement et de
lutre contre l'habitat indigne la
mobilité des ultramarins est une autre
priorité forte de ce but budget avec une
montée en puissance des moyens dédiés à
la continuité territoriale ce qui
permettra notamment une hausse du seuil
de ressources pour les public
bénéficiire de l'aide à la continuité
territoriale qui passera vous l'avez
indiqué Monsieur le Ministre tout à
l'heure à 18000 € par part de cootient
familial les aides à la mobilité seront
également renforcé pour des publics
cibles les étudiants les actifs les
talents de la Culture et du Sport ainsi
qu'en matière sociale l'agence de
l'outreemre pour la mobilité va se
réformer pour devenir le cœur de la
mobilité en outreem et améliorer le
service rendu aux ultramarins enfin les
dispositifs d'accompagnement des
collectivités territoriales doivent
continuer à
s'étaufer ils sont déterminants pour
accompagner les communes en difficultés
financières et soutenir les
collectivités ultramarines pour
l'ingénierie nécessaire à la réalisation
de leur projets structurant notamment
dans de domaines comme l'eau
l'assaainissement la rudologie et cetera
il est en effet nécessaire de maintenir
leur capacités financière afin de
favoriser l'égal accès aux services
publics locaux d'apporter une aide
d'urgence financière et humaine aux
populations et au collectivité frappé
notamment lors de des conditions
climatiques extrêmes d'appuyer également
les actions en matière de sécurité et de
défense civile c'est pourquoi le groupe
horizon et apparenté votera en faveur de
cette mission budgétaire telle qu'elle
est proposée initialement merci pour le
groupe écologiste Sandrine Rousseau et
pour 4
minutes
alors je pass mon tour parce que je pas
je pas le je passe monour bon ok
alors David ran pour pour le le groupe
GDR
merci merci monsieur le Président ou
c'est bon là ah il faut savoirin bon
allez on revient en arrière
exceptionnellement pour Madame Sandrine
Rousseau 4 minutes pour la discussion
générale sur cette mission outre mer mes
excuses je suis désolée parce que je
suis non ordonnée alors en mai 2022
l'appel de Fort de forance réclamait un
changement profond politique outreemè de
l'État déplorant une situation de
maldéveloppement structurel dans
l'essentiel des territoires ultramarins
et si ce CR d'urgence ce cri d'exigence
vis-à-vis de l'État français appelle
évidemment une évolution
institutionnelle pour sortir du
paradigme de la carence structurelle et
de la dépendance vis-à-vis de la France
hexagonale il demande aussi la mise à
disposition de moyens suffisants pour
permettre à ces territoires de relever
les défis sociau écologiques économiques
et culturels auquels ils font face avec
une augmentation de crédit de seulement
5 % donc bien inférieure à l'inflation
nous pouvons dire que malgré les
annonces le gouvernement loupe le coche
pour ce 2e PLF consécutif le budget
comporte certes quelques adaptations et
améliorations mais il ne procède pas à
aucune rupture par rapport à la
situation actuellement vécue dans les
territoires d'outrem or c'est justement
d'un budget de R ture d'un quoi qu'il en
coûte ultramarin dont nous aurions
besoin aux problématiques structurelles
sur lesquelles nos collègues ultramarins
ne cessent de nous interpeller pauvreté
chômage manque de service chireté des
produits importés se sont ajouté
d'autres crises l'inflation la crise de
l'au à Mayotte et en Guadeloupe la
contamination au chlore d'écones dans
les anentilles la prolifération des
sargas où sont donc les moyens pour
répondre à la hauteur de ces enjeux où
sont les investissements massifs dans
les infrastructures dans l'économie
locale pour vendre ces territoires
indépendants et autonomes sur le plan de
l'énergie et de l'alimentation où est la
transformation de la gouvernance de ces
territoires destiné à associer bien
davantage les populations locales à leur
destiné où se trouve le volet
d'adaptation au réchauffement climatique
pourtant très prégnant dans ces
territoirees Mayotte connaît une
sécheresse historique mais ces
territoires possèdent une biodiversité
d'une richesse incroyable 80 % de la
biodiversité française est située dans
les territoires d'outrem qui offre à
notre pays la deuxème zone et économique
exclusif mondial qu'est-il fait pour
contrecarrer la perte de biodiversité où
sont les budgets qui permettent de
traiter la question de la réparation des
populations contaminées par le chlore
des connes où est le plan Marshal
demandé par les collectivités
ultramarines pour faire face à la
pollution des déchets où sont les
investissements massifs pour garantir un
accès à l'eau potable pour tous et
toutes ce budget s'encre malheureusement
dans le monde d'avant alors que les
alertes se multiplient pour que nous
passions à autre chose car les crises
écologiques et sociales se nourrissent
entre elles on le constate aujourd'hui
sur l'eau et on le verra dans de
nombreux autres domaines dans les années
qui viennent le groupe écologiste
présentera plusieurs amendements pour
améliorer ce budget mais appelle le
gouvernement à une véritable bifurcation
de ses politiques en matière de
territoire ultramarin merci pour le
groupe Gauche démocrate et républicaine
David David pardon riman
ouais merci Président c'est
David donc euh France donc on dit Davi
non monsieur c'est le prénom de de mes
parents donc c'est Davy
euh ça ça ça je je Tu voilà tu
m'excuseras ça sera pour tous ceux qui
prononcent Hervan à la place d'Erwan
voilà il y a pas de souci donc euh merci
euh président monsieur le ministre
monsieur rapporteur chers collègues
euh je rentrerai pas dans le débat des
chiffres parce que on s'est déjà exprimé
certains collègues ont plus ou moins
résumer la la réalité tant sur la LBU et
et et d'autres choses euh mais après
j'aimerais juste quand même faire
rappeler un petit détail concernant
l'inflation je sais pas d'où vous AZ
pris le le chiffre de 5 % en matire
d'inflation peut-re c'est celui de
l'Hexagone mais lorsqu'on RRE dans la
réalité sur nos territoires euh les
collectivités lorsqu'on fait un point
avec les dépenses aujourd'hui il y a un
delta aujourd'hui d'une majoration de 30
% sur le chiffrage par rapport à l'année
dernière donc les 5 % dont vous parlez
je ne sais pas d'où est-ce qu'ils
tienent j'aurais bien aimé savoir d'où
vient ces 5 % là concrètement parce que
nous on n pas la même lecture par
rapport à la réalité de no territoire
ensuite le collègue Nilor a rappelé la
réité de LBU c'est juste un rattrapage
de niveau connu de
2010 bon qu quand vous consentez à dire
qu' un effort qui a été fait n on dit
que c'est un rattrapage qui qui s'est
opéré ces dernières
années certains ici se disent que le
budget il est bon il est pas mal il y a
un effort qui est fait le ministre n de
cesse de le dire partout o il passe il y
a un effort conséquent qui est fait de
la part de l'État en matière
budgétaire mais lorsqu'on regarde que
comment le budget est constitué au
travers du budget vous n'allez jamais
réussir à régler le problèmes qu'il y a
sur no territoire tant qu' restera dans
dispositif du budget tel qu'il est fait
vous ne réglerez jamais les problèmes
qu'il y a sur no territoire quand le dis
très clairement donc j'entends bien il y
a eu pas mal de d'amendements qui ont
été votés qui ont complètement modifié
le budget initial présenté par l'État
concernant l' prèire je je nous ne
sommes pas DUP hein nous savons très
bien que il y a une très grosse majorité
qui vont être liquidé comme l'année
dernière à l'essu du 493 qui arrive à à
à grandes enjambé
euh mais néanmoins euh on va pas moi je
pas prre mon temps à parler aujourd'hui
du budget tel qu' est décliné euh parce
que ça va rien changer dans l'absolu
euh pour pour le collègue au niveau du
rapport j'ai un souci parce que l'État
et et vous euh vous vous aimez faire des
comparaisons alors qu' qu' n'ont pas
lieu d'être souvent vous mettez la guyan
et Mayotte sur le même prisme c'est une
faute que vous faites et je don juste un
chiffre qui est non négligeable Mayot
c'est un peu moins de 400 km² la Guyane
c'est 89000 km² Mayot a une densité de
près de 800 habitants par kilmè carré la
Guen c'est 4 habitants par kilomè carré
Mayot est une île la guenne est surous
un continent qu'il a comme frontière
deux fleuves donc vous aurez beau dire
qu'il y a pas assez de moyen pour gérer
gérer les frontières comment vous faites
pour euh pourouvoir euh gérer un fleuve
qui fait plus de de plus de 400 m pas
400 km de long c'est c'est du domaine de
l'impossible et nous aujourd'hui au
regard de la Guyane on parle de nos
fleuves pas comme des frantièr mais des
bassins de vie l'approche qui do fait en
mare d'immigration doit être différente
c'est pas voir quelle politique
immigratoire on doit faire c'est comment
on on on met en place un accueil dis de
ceom pour éviter justement la
prolifération de bidonville quand les
gens arrivent et qu'il n'y a pas de
gestion qui est fait de ces personnesl
les gens besoin de se mettre un toit
auudessus de la tête donc oui il vont il
y aura des bidonvillees c'est comment
faire de façon collective qui n'est pas
de bidonville c'est accueillir ces
personnesl leur dire ce qui est possible
ou pas et après traiter les dossiers les
un les autres et là où il fautire faut
mettre des moyens et arrêter de dire que
l'insécurité qui a sur no territoire est
du à
l'immigration ça le don de mériter
mériter le poil vous n'avez pas la même
approche comme ça concernant d'autres
situations donc il y a des réalités
certes mais il faut faire le distingo
ensuite moi je serai pas plus long la
mesure pour dire vous savez chers
collègues vous allez voter le budget où
il y aura le 493 et la majorité dit que
c'est bon je vous dis que le budget il
est pas bon il n'aurait pas les
problèmes de nos territoires et il va
falloir vraiment qu'on change de
paradigme quant à l'approche économique
sociale sanitaire de nos territoires et
ce avec urgence j'en a fini monsieur le
Président merci pour conclure monsieur
Stéphane normand donc pour conclure
cette première série de questions
j'invite ceux qui ont des questions
après que le ministre ait répondu de me
le signaler dès maintenant s'il vous
plaît oui mais ça vous avez déjà posé
des questions ça ne marchera pas pour
vous c'est bien tenté monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour pour le groupe Liot merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues j'entends souvent que les
autremes sonent une chance pour la
République un véritable à tout si notre
groupe Liot souscrit à cette vision il
tient à vous rappeler que cette chance
vous oblige mais nous oblige en
septembre vous annonciez une progression
significative des crédits autre Mair
signe d'une volonté forte du
gouvernement mais lorsque l'on prend en
compte l'inflation on peut au mieux
noter une stabilité du budget ce qui
dans un contexte budgétaire peut sembler
lourd ble mais il ne faut pas tomber
dans la caricature et il faut aussi
reconnaître que depuis des années le
quotidien de nos territoires ultramarin
est bien éloigné de la réalité
hexagonale chez nous la promesse
d'égalité réelle et de fraternité n'est
pas tenue la grande pauvreté par exemple
touche 5 à 10 fois plus les départements
ultramarin que l'hexagone en cause des
salaires bas une vie plus chère mais
aussi en cause un manque de volonté
politique pour per des écarts qui
s'installent et qui se creuse chaque
année nous attendons une révolution
budgétaire et politique qui ne vient pas
prenez par exemple la question de
l'habitat 70000 logements précaires ou
indiges sont comptabilisés dans les 5
départements d'outre mè il représent à
eux seul 13 % des logements insalubles
français pour seulement 4 % de la
population la ligne budgétaire a été
augmentée cette année mais elle devra
l'être pendant de nombreuses années pour
rattraper le retard ce texte entend
aussi accompagner la mobilité des
ultramarins avec notamment
l'élargissement du public bénéficiaire
de la continuité territoriale nous
disons enfin puisque c'était une
proposition qui avait été portée par
notre groupe dans sa niche autre
priorité devrait être celle de l'acé
allô hein comme vous le savez c'est un
sujet qui est cher à ma collègue estal
Youssoufa à Mayotte mais aussi à Olivier
serva et Mac matiazin en Guadeloupe ce
projet de loi finance prévoit le soutien
au syndicat mixte de gestion et
d'assainissement des EAU DE de la
Guadeloupe avec une dotation de 20
millions d'euros nous estimons qu'il
faut aller plus loin et nous demandons
que les Guadeloupéens et les Maoris
voient leur factur prise en charge en
cas de coupure d'eau cette majorité
mettra en avant une hausse des crédits
dédiés à la mission nous autres
ultramarins savons qu'elle masque des
années de sous-investissement dont vous
n'êtes pas non plus monsieur monsieur le
ministre le seul responsable rappelons
par ailleurs que le déficit d'ingénierie
et vous en avez parlé aboutira sans
doute à une sous-consommation des
crédits et retardera le développement
des projets sur nos territoires il faut
essayer d'y remédier mais monsieur le
ministre si nous avons par exemple eu
beaucoup d'amendements qui ont été
validés en commission et notamment en
commission des finances on peut pas
entre guillemets effacer l'arbitrage et
le 493 qui arrivera et de nouveau la
défiance vis-à-vis du gouvernement se
risque de s'installer dans les autres
mères je prendrai trois exemples dans
deux concern mon territoire nous avions
un amendement qui proposait de répartir
80 % des crédits sur la biodiversité
c'était pas une augmentation de crédit
c'était un fléchage nouveau ça a été
refusé euh le prochain contrat état
région concernant Saint-Pierre et Milan
il sera en baisse par rapport au
précédent j'ai porter trois amendements
qui ont franchi le cap de la commission
des finances l'un concernant les
infrastructures portuaires qui sont
délaboré et qui relève de la compétence
de l'État j'ai porté aussi sur la
déconstruction d'un ancien hôpital qui
bloque aujourd'hui des projets de
revitalisation de du centre-ville et la
construction d'un épade ou encore celui
de la nécessaire transition comment dire
énergétique sur mon territoire puisque
nous sommes le territoire où presque 40
% du budget des familles part dans le
chauffage et j'ai peur qu'avec les
arbitrages et le 493 tout cela va être
gommé un peu comme l'an passé créant une
nouvelle frustration mais je suis par
nature optimiste je terminerai sur deux
aspects positifs il reste un ministre
qui a une grande expérience d'élus local
et qui nous a annoncé qu'il travaillera
mieux le budget 2025 et il nous reste à
Saint-Pierre et miiclan un préfet qui a
installé une bonne entente de travail
avec les élus locaux alors vous me direz
c'est naturellement bien insuffisant eu
égard au défi que nous avons à relever
monsieur le ministre mais je crois que
c'est quand même un préalable si vous
êtes d'accord pour retrousser nos
manches avec nous sans tomber dans les
grand messes qui ont caractérisé le le
premier quinquena il nous faut du
pragmatisme en outre-em euh nous y
sommes prêts à travailler au niveau du
groupe liberté indépendant outr-emè
territoire un problème une solution et
ces solutions doivent se construire
territoire par territoire
merci merci donc nous on a neu questions
une réponse monsieur le ministre commune
pour chacun merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs les députés je vais essayer
d'être le plus complet vous dire
qu'évidemment je mesure combien la tâche
est immense combien les attentes sont
grandes combien certains l'ont dit le
retard é important et combien il peut y
avoir des frustrations et j'entends tout
cela et pour parcourir ces territoires
il y a des solutions inacceptables quand
on parle de l'eau je regarde madame
Rousseau mais je crois avoir marqué
beaucoup d'indignation en tout cas
croyez bien JEE également le député
camardine qui est à côté c'est que dès
demain soir je repars pour maotte moi je
veux absolument qu'on mette à la fois
les moyens sur la table mais qu' a une
sensibilisation générale le gouvernement
seul ne peut rien il peut faire beaucoup
mais c'est une affaire collective et
quand je dis l'eau c'est le logement
enfin bref toutes les sujets sont sont
concernés en tout cas cette logique de
coconstruction dans laquelle je
m'inscris j'irai au bout de cette
logique parce qu'il n'y a pas de
solution miracle et en tout cas c'est
pas moi seul qui peut l'apporter je au
rapporteur c'est normal il dans son rôle
je l' étaé avant lui sur d'autres
questions donc je peux comprendre qu'on
passe tout au vitriol en expliquant que
rien ne va alors je vrais simplement
remettre deux trois petites choses dans
leur contexte voyez il faut que vous
sachiez que sur les effectifs la
gendarmerie nationale ils ont augmenté
de 10 % 5 ans sur la police nationale
ils ont augmenté de 21 % donc je ne peux
pas laisser dire qu'on n rien fait je
vais pas vous infliger des chiffres que
l'on a vécu à une époque c'était pas
cela je faut dire les titres de séjours
par c'est tellement facile de dire les
chiffres 2022 15545 ties de sé jour j'ai
les chiffres là je peux vous les
communiquer en
2023 je ne suis plus qu'à moins de 11000
ça veut dire en clair on est en
régression force sa éloignements les TF
auxquels vous êtes sensibles les ecttf
un sujet dont vous parlez souvent
2022 313 là on fait 10 % de plus on a
3459 sur les éloignements on est en
progression de 30 % c'est le
nonadmission sur le territoire on va
augmenter de 20 % donc que tout soit pas
parfait bien sûr mais je ne peux pas
laisser dire qu'on met pas les moyens
géralmanin je crois a développé beaucoup
de moyens pour faire en sorte que sur
les ties de séjour sur l'éloignement sur
les forces de sécurité intérieur sur le
trafic de
stupéfiants trafic de stupéfiants 71 kg
de cocaïne saisie et il y a eu
simplement 877 interdiction
d'embarquement ça n'est pas rien vous
allez à l'aéroport à Cayenne je CIS vous
étiez il y a pas longtemps en guyan vous
avez remarqué que tout le monde est
contrôlé donc je pense que on a fait un
certain nombre d'efforts il faut
continuer entendez bien dans mon message
hors de questions de ne pas continuer
d'intensifier de plus collaborer avec la
justice et de faire en sorte mais pas
exemple en guyan parce que je sais que
vous êtes inquiété de ce sujetl vous
m'avez pas posé la question je suis très
heureux de vous répondre la prison des
saint-leurand du marouni est bien prévue
avec 500 places elles seront elle seront
opérationnelle en 2027 et de même vous
dire quand même que sur la prise en
compte des jeunes au titre de la PJJ
c'est plus de 1000 mineurs qui ont été
pris en charge en 2023 et des brigades
de soutien qui ont été créés et puisque
vous voulez savoir ce qui a été fait je
pense le seul exemple de la Guyane mais
je pourrais vous donner pour d'autres
territoires ultramarins ce sera 47
postes qui sont créées de magistrats à
Cayenne je crois que c'est un effort
important qui certes peut ne paraître
pas suffisant mais au moins accordez-moi
qu'il est sur la table sur l'hôpital je
vous dis un chiffre il y a des députés
de de la Guyane ça ça bien mieux que moi
si vous dites demain que les padus sont
dehors en clair des praticiens qui sont
qui ont un diplôme hors Union Européenne
ça veut dire que 70 % des médecins ne
seront plus là si on va au bout de votre
logique on ferme des hôpitaux en Guyon
comment on le ferme ailleurs d'ailleurs
qument on les ferme dans l'Hexagone les
chiffres sont disponibles et il
retracent que la vérité vous savez très
bien ce que c'est que l' Pasu et on en a
régularisé d'ailleurs il y a moins d'un
ans un certain nombre parce qu'ils
avaient la compétence au titre ce qu'on
appelle de la VAE laidation des acquis
de l'expérience et à Mayotte nous avons
mobilisé je le dis devant député
camarani notamment la réserve sanitaire
qui est arrivée encore au nombre de 53 à
la demande du ministre de la Santé et ma
demande puisque reconnaître
reconnaissons tout simplement que les
soignants étaient à bout de souffle et
je les comprends 1000 fois donc monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez fait 10
propositions B écoutez nous aurons par
exemple le projet de loi sur
l'immigration vous aurez le temps de
vous exprimer vous direz quelle est
votre vision des choses il y aura le
projet de loi de Mayotte personne n'en a
parlé mais il fait partie des mesuresom
sur lesquels nous aurons l'occasion en
2024 de nous exprimer mais dans vos 10
propositions il y a déjà au moins quatre
que j'ai noté pour lesquels nous
apportons singulièrement des réponses
avec les chiffres que je viens de vous
donner j'espère au moins que vous en
donnerez acte à défaut d'adhérer mais
c'est normal supposer je comprends et je
respecte je voudrais remercier Guillaume
Butet de de son intervention d'abord
d'avoir regarderé les choses et d'avoir
expliqué que Jean-François Carenco en en
inventant avec Gérald Darmanin et la
première ministre le sium c'est une
belle démarche suite à l'appel de fort-
de France vous l' aavez dit Madame
rousseo c'est une belle démarche que
pour une fois on commençait à parler des
territoires ultrarins euh pas uniquement
en disant comme la culture c'est ce qui
reste lorsqu'on a tout oublié mais
quelle est leur singularité comment
demain on va mieux prendre en compte les
ultramarins et donc ce rendez-vous du 18
2023 lequel vous étiez extrêmement actif
euh vous le savez puisque tous les
parlementaires vous êtes déjà déjà tous
invités le 23 et 24 novembre il y aura
territoire par territoire ça permet de
de répondre à notre collègue collègue
qui du groupe pilote qui m'a interpellé
tout à l'heure monsieur Lenormand en
disant que ces rendez-vous permettront
territoire par territoire parlementair
et grands élus comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure responsable des collectivité de
voir les mesures sur mais pas que les
mesures surom et merci à Guillaume vit
d'avoir rappelé qu'on est passé entre
2016 et 2024 de 2 milliards à 3
milliards certains sont intervenus tout
à l'heure c'est dommage ils ne sont plus
là parce que j'aurais moi j'ai regardé
un peu ce qui avait été dépensé vous
voyez en autorisation de programme et en
crédit de paiement entre 2012 et 2017
c'est toujours un exercice intéressant
de comparer même comparaison des pas
raison ça permet de voir où est-ce que
l'effort a été fait merci donc d'avoir
rappelé que les CCT on augmenté de 400
millions d'euros que la LBU était porté
à 300 millions d'euros même si ce qui a
dit le député Nilor est parfaitement
jute et je viendrai dans une seconde et
il m'a posé une question sur le fameux
rapport sur le fret je réponds sans
détour nous l'avons reçu les transmis au
secrétat général du gouvernement il ne
va pas tarder à arrivriver j'ai pris
bonne note avec l'équipe qui m'entoure
je vous promets Guillaume V nous avons
casasion d'échanger il y a pas très très
longtemps sur les budgets outremè parce
que vous les connaissez parfaitement
bien et vous êtes passionné pour ce
territoire je m'engage devant la
commission des lois monsieur le
Président à vous transmettre ces
éléments enfin sur le le coût du fret
les différence vous avez insisté sur
l'aide apportée par l'État c'est vrai
que cette aide elle est en fait elle est
bicéphale et à fois apporté par l'État
et fois apporté par les régions qui ne
sont pas toujours avec le même régime
d'aide pour les régions et ça crée des
notions de distorsion voyez dans les
débats du sium et dans puisquon aura des
discussions à avoir je pense que c'est
un élément important madame Goulet vous
étiez évidemment sur des des thématiques
que je respecte parfaitement et et qui
sont assez proche de votre rapporteur
c'est une opération de communication
vous savez madame moi je suis pas dans
une opération de communication si vous
doutez vous venez de m'assir avec moi
maotte et vous verrez le député
camardine était présent j'ai présidé un
comité de l'eau il était là j'en
représiderai un d'ailleurs
mercredi et on parle demain sir à 20h20
si elle veut venir il y a pas de
problème elle verra un que c'est
transparent deux que tout le monde peut
s'exprimer tro que que la presse est là
je vous invite juste à méditer tout cela
parce que c'est pas une coopération de
communication vous savez moi je regarde
ça une immunité
immense parce que je vais au contact des
populations et je vois ce qui se passe
et comment en est-on là faut qu'on
s'interroge quand 34 % des habitants
pour l'instant n'ont pas de réseau qui
soit connectés vous voyez on a tous élu
de territoire j'imagine ce qui se
passerait dans l'Hexagone si on avait ce
constat permanent vous avez parlé des
prix ça me permet de dire sur la vie
chère il y a eu peu d'interventions mais
il y a des choses qui qui sont
prévisibles et qui sont prévus pardon
d'abord la réforme de l'roit de mer là
aussi dans la concertation dans la
coconstruction on va pas sortir
brutalement euh soit de Bercy soit euh
euh de du ministère des outremèes du
ministère de l'Intérieur et des
outremèes non euh j'annonce que à tous
les territoires comme je me suis engagé
j'aienviré une matrice une maquette de
de de l'octroit de mer territoire par
territoire parce qu'il est différent sur
les territoires on verra bien quelle est
la part lié auctit de mer comment par
qui est-il levé à qui revient-il aux
communes aux régions on verra quel com
quel est le niveau de TVA comment il
s'applique de manière à ce que chacun
puisse comprendre comment ça marche
après il y a une démarche qui se fera
dans chacun des territoires autour du
groupe de travail autour des préfets et
vous serez les parlementaires tous
associés j'ai pas oublié quand même que
j'ai été longtemps dans cette maison
pour estimer qu'il fallait que les
parlementaires soient là à tout moment
de manière à ce que vous puissiez
naturellement vous ensaisir sur le prix
du carburant alors ça c'est je regarde
les collègues de de la Guyane il sa
c'est un un un chantier que je démarre
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a un
problème de prix des carburants
notamment Antig guuyane sur la mission
monopole vous savez quelqu'un a dit que
on avait fait avec Gérald dermanin un
coup de bluff pas du tout Gérald
dermanin Bruno Lemer et votre serviteur
ont signé un courrier qui va permettre à
la commission des affaires économiques
on va s'appuyer sur les parlementaires
de l'Assemblée nationale avec une n de
mission gouvernementale de nous éclairer
sur ces notion de monopole je crois
qu'on va dire les choses simplement on
va regarder et on verra là où il y a un
problème j'ai cru comprendre dans les PL
dans les déplacements que j'ai pu faire
que cet annonce était pas toujours reçu
avec une immense chaleur nous irons au
bout de la démarche parce que les
monopoles sont là à un certain nombre de
moments sur l'aide aux intran sur les
agriculteurs vous savez qu'il y a un
plan qui avait été donné par la première
ministre lorsqu'elle avait fait son
déplacement à la Réunion au mois de mai
et lorsque je suis allé en Martinique
j'ai annoncé que il y aurait des
possibilités notamment pour certains
agriculteurs d'en bénéficier et puis
enfin sur le sur le problème de l'emploi
je rappelle qu'un seul territoire était
territoire expérimental c'était la
réunion pourfire ce travail je souhaite
qu'on puisse élargir très rapidement aux
autres territoires en tout cas je
voudrais pas que ça reste ainsi la
laadom j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
l'iletri j'en ai dit un mot et je pense
sur fiscale j'en ai parlé enfin vous
avez dit Madame sur wouchou tout ça
c'est une opération de communication
mais écoutez nous sommes lundi mercredi
il y aura nous continuons les
instructions s'est engagé on sera plus
de 1300 habitats totalement ins salu ou
d'ailleurs on reconstruit certes ça
pourrait être plus certes il faut faire
toujours mieux mais reconnaissez au
moins que il a fallu un peu de courage
la détermination protéger ses opérations
et le ministre de l'intérieur a été
présent au rendez-vous merci à
Jean-Philippe nor pour la tonalité de
son intervention d'avoir souligné pour
la la LBU il a raison il a raison
lorsqu'il dit que en 2010 c'était 289
millions d'euros on est revenu au niveau
de 2010 oui vous avez raison monsieur le
député et pourquoi ça VVC pour une
raison simple parce que j'ai eu un peu
la curiosité de regarder c'est un
problème de consommation des crédit il
faut qu'on consomme ces crédits ça ne
sert à rien je je l'ai D avec beaucoup
d'humidité tout à l'heure oui mais c'est
pas je dis au député camardine que c'est
pas nous qui qui sommes les bâtisseurs
vous m'accorderez bien qu'il y a des
collectivités il y a les organismes
d'état ou des organis public ou parapu
qui interviennent mais ne m'accusez
quand même pas de ne pas être le
battuseur ou alors vous voulez qu'on
nationalise tout quelque part ça serait
un peu différent des convictions
politiques qui vous animent parce que je
crois que vous êtes quand même
profondément décentralisateurs c'est
vrai qu'on revient au niveau de 2010
dontacte vous avez raison monsieur le
député et qu'il faillent des plans
purriannuels oui quand je suis à la
Réunion j'ai demandé un plan purriannuel
mais je sais qu'en c'est un sujet en
Guadeloupe c'est un sujet on a PR
foncier d'ailleurs en Guyane le
président de la délégation est à côté de
vous et je lui ai proposé qu'on se
reparle sur cette question parce que moi
aussi je veux savoir quelle est
l'approche des parlementaires le parce
qu'il y a des collectivités d'un côté il
y a l'état qui est propriétaire des 95 %
des fonciers mais il y a pas de raison
que on puisse pas avec vous trouver des
solutions enfin sur les risques majeurs
parce que m'ave interpellé vous avez
bien fait vous avez quand même vu que le
lendemain de Tami j'étais sur place la
demande du président de la première
ministre Géral Herin a déclenché
catastrophe naturelle immédiatement mais
les fonds barniers sont disponibles et
ces fonds barniers on peut les utiliser
et enfin vous avez posé une vraie
question c'est celle du RSA pas le
revenu de solidarité active mais l' ça
là où il y a des discussions à conduire
le niveau actuel n'a pas été revalorisé
ça n'est pas acceptable et nous avons
entamer des discussions avec les autres
ministères en interministériel j'en
profite quand même pour rappeler pour
les aides agricoles le PI est toujours à
320 million d'euros et que vous savez
qu'il peut y avoir une a complémentaire
de la France par rapport au pzi dans ce
budget 2024 elle passe de 45 à 60
millions d'euros donc il y a un effort
complémentaire qui est fait ça ne règle
pas le problème de RSA merci d'avoir
encore attiré la vigilance vous êtes le
seul à avoir fait mais j'y tiens et je
vous tiendrai au courant naturellement
de l'évolution de ce que vous avez dit
et me permettraz juste une petite
coquetterie sur votre texte sur la PPL
que vous annonciz donc je crois qu'il
pardon PPR pardon PPR mais elle
s'inscrira dans une niche parlementaire
donc j'imagine que vous aurez tout le
poids nécessaire pour faire en sorte
qu'elle soit en haut de la niche qu'elle
ne soit pas oubliée de manière qu'elle
puisse
entendu et je serais heureux d'être au
ban si je peux vous
répondre alors ensuite jeens au député
camardine on se connaît bien parce qu'on
se voit régulièrement j'imagine qu'on va
encore passer deux jours ensemble vous
avez pu le voir je pense que mon
engagement n'est pas fin vous l'avez
reconnu vous-même dans la presse locale
en disant que quand même on commença à
se donner les moyens et d'ailleurs vous
serez associé vous le savez très bien
vous êtes venu me voir l'autre jour pour
savoir comment on pour être plus
efficace l'état seul je vous le répète
ne peut pas faire l'État ne peut pas
donner des instructions au syndicat des
eau et à toute structure qui s'occupe
d'eau d'assaainissement de route il y a
des compétences c'est qu'il y a du
retard sur la Maillotte j'en suis
totalement convaincu sur la santé mais
là c'est plus notre affaire là c'est à
nous à faire en sorte que la promesse
présidentielle de la construction
d'abord l'agrandissement la construction
du hôpital de Mayotte soit réalisé j'ai
d'ailleurs écrit aéen Rousseau pour
demander un program un programmiste de
manière à ce qu'on puisse rentrer dans
les phases actives parce que ça
justement il faut le faire donc vous
voyez je vais dans votre sens en
revanche sur l'au j'imagine que je vais
vous retrouver sur mon chemin enfin du
moins on sera côte à côte et non face à
face comme nous sommes là de manière ce
que vous avez parlé des créditmobilisés
oui vous avez raison mais je vous
rappelle monsieur camardine sur le
précédent CCT 2019 2022 vous m'en ferez
pas reproche j'étais pas en
responsabilité très bien 70 millions
prévus 30 millions 30 millions engagés
non m'z posé une question je vous
réponds sans esprit polémique tout
simplement 30 millions prévus 30
millions engagés 8 millions seulement
payés faut pas faire reproche à l'état
lorsqu'il met de l'argent sur la table
que derrière les crédits de paiement
n'est pas suivi c'est quand même pas un
reproche qu'on peut me faire les fameux
411 millions oui vous avez raison et
bien faisons en sorte fait avec moi pour
que enfin on apporte au maorés la
réponse qu'il mérite d'avoir et sayez
très bien que là-dessus je l'ai dit sans
détour à Mayotte en votre présence à
plusieurs reprises et j'imagine que vous
serez avec moi pour aller voir le
premier forage voyez je veux dire on a
lancé un forage le 2 septembre et bien
il marche il fait 500 m C par jour on
ira le voir d'ailleurs mercredi matin
tous les deux à Fr gums merci de nous
faire confiance pour ce dialogue de la
coconstruction il a pu voir notamment il
nous avait sensibilisé sur Action
Logement que il a été non seulement
écouté mais il a été entendu parce que
j'ai pu l'annoncer en arrivant sur le
territoire il a parlé des déplacements
ent les bassins de vie oui on a un sujet
je vous dis très librement moi si a
c'est certains ici ont des suggestions à
me faire sur le transport aérien je vous
rappelle que le gouvernement massivement
a soutenu transport aérien il y a
plusieurs compagnies qu' qui ont
bénéficié de soutien financier
d'ailleurs des régions la région la rue
union est investi massivement on pas
loin de 300 millions d'euros sur le
transport arien au moins de 4 ans mais
après on a les capillaires on a les
dessertes locales on a les dessertes
locaurégional et quand on est en Guyane
c'est comment on va au Suriname comment
comment on va à Sainte-Lucie comment on
va en République Dominicaine pareil pour
la Martinique et bien sûr et la
Guadeloupe comment lorsque nous sommes à
la Réunion et bien on va à Maurice enfin
toutes ces questions là se posent et
c'est vrai que j fr gum que évidemment
c'est très cher je me suis renseigné il
y a 4 jours sur le prix des billets j'en
ai totalement conscience et ce que nous
voulons faire en terme d' de rayonnement
géopolitique de tous ces territoires
l'Indien bien sûr la Caraïbe et et puis
bien sûr ce qui se passe en Polynésie
exige qu'on ait une nouvelle politique
en matière de transport aérien et on
sera amené à faire des propositions j'ai
déjà vu Clément bon pour voir comment on
pouvait faire des nouvelles
modélisations qui ne sont quelque part à
l'heure actuelle un peu à bout de souv
Gérard leol merci d'avoir appelé que la
vichur était au cœur de de de vos sujets
euh avec 500 millions d'euros pas moins
pas moins de 500 million d'euros sur un
amendement ce qui une somme assez
considérable bon je vois que
malheureusement il sera pas là pour
m'écouter mais de dire que il parlait
quand même des des fameux CCT les
contrats de continuité de convergence et
de transformation qui ont augmenté de
400 million c'est quand même un effort
il nous a demandé si sur les sargass on
faisait quelque chose madame Rousseau
d'ailleurs m'a posé la question oui
madame Rousseau nous augmentons de d'un6
les crédit sur les sargas et nous serons
à 6 mlions4 avec je vous l'annonce je
serai le 2 décembre à Dea nous prenons à
échelle internationale parce qu'on peut
pas régler seul ce sujetl qui est un
sujet absolument majeur qu'on a d'abord
la source de la création de ces sargas
on les a identifié auprès des fleuves
concernés absolument et c'est nous qui
avons créé le Gy comme le rappelle le
président de de la commission je suis
très heureux de de retrouver ce Gy
d'ailleurs il fallait le créer c'est la
France qui a peut-être de pont en la
matière qui finance d'ailleurs le plus
nous finançons 60 % de l'effort
international sur les sargaz je vais
aller plaider pour expliquer pour avoir
constaté de mesures des sarglass la
semaine dernière c'est une véritable
émie et qu'il faut absolument gommer et
en tout cas compter sur mon engagement
pour comprendre et jusqu'à un sujet qui
vous est cher madame Rousseau c'est la
valorisation de cessar gaz parce que
production de gaz et quelquefois une
possibilité vers la méthanisation donc
je vais voir comment on pourrait y
arriver voyez à la fois la source le
traitement et et ensuite la valorisation
merci à Marie agè puier vinbach je me
suis pas trop vbach pardon excusez-moi
cher collègue pardon madame la députée
sur et merci d'avoir noté les efforts
que nous avons fait notamment sur la
contrisation de logement sur la
continuité territoriale avec les
mobilités et les efforts que nous
faisons c'est vrai en Guadeloupe en
guad-eloupe assez fier que pour la
première fois l'état l'eau la région et
le département étai là tous ensemble
avec une planification je vous assure
que j'étais plutôt très heureux de voir
qu'il y avait des dates qui étaient
posées il y avait 25 opérations prévues
une triple signature un engagement de
close de revoyur je dis ça pour le le
député camaradine tous les mois tous les
mois conseil de l'eau
dans la Guadeloupe je trouve que c'est
bien où tous les acteurs seront là euh
donc je pense que c'est un pe une sorte
nouvelle voie que nous explorons en tout
cas moi je l'appelle de mes vœux si on
peut ensemble avancer pour pour Mayotte
mais voyez un régime un peu sévère mais
qui me paraît important et puis merci
d'avoir rappelé les capacités
financières et puis vous avez interrogé
sur la sécurité je crois au début de mon
intervention en répondant au rapporteur
j'ai j'ai donné des éléments sur la
sécurité même s'il les trouve
insuffisant il aura pu constater que
l'augmentation était là que les moyens
éé qu sur la table madame Rousseau vous
avez rappelé Fort De France Le sium donc
du 2 juillet 2023 la déclinaison que
j'ai expliquer donc il y aura je vous le
reprécise quatre rendez-vous d'ici
juillet 24 avec les élus parlementaires
pour faire vivre le sium mais pas que le
sium certains m'ont demandé parce que
des mesures qui n'ont pas été retenues
dans le seum il y avait plus de 200
mesures donc 72 sont celles qui ont été
retenues de manière à ce que l'on puisse
élargir nos réflexions et en tout cas je
crois que c'est une démarche assez
nouvelle j'irais jusqu'au bout comptez
sur moi vous avez interoger sur les
énergies renouvelables vous savez que
vous qui êtes attaché à la transition
énergétique mais écoutez on est à 60 %
de production d'énergie renouvelable les
ultramarins sont devant ce qui se passe
l'Hexagone c'est c'est au moins cela et
avec un un objectif d'être en 2030 à à
zé à zéro émission de gaz et effet de
ser donc c'est quand même un effet très
intéressant vous m'avez parlé de la
clore desconne alors la clore descne
écoutez j'ai présidé il y il y a 3
semaines à la Martinique une réunion on
sort enfin de ce drame et j'ai utilisé
des mots je crois très fort euh ce matin
d'ailleurs devant les agriculteurs euh
93 millions d'euros à la clé sur le plan
clord d'cones qui je crois est en cas
d'être bien accepté par les acteurs les
associations étaient là il y a un chemin
de confiance qui commence à se bâtir il
faudra le solidifier au fil du temps
j'en ai ple pleinement conscience j'ai
trouvé plutôt une assemblée apaisée sur
la question en tout cas il faut faire
une réparation ce qui s'est passé
scandaleux en matière de transparence
euh il y a des des prises en charge qui
existent maintenant il rappelle que
toutes les analyses de de terre les an
anal de son sont gratuites c'est normal
les dossiers sont montés dans les
mairies nous avons une convention avec
l'association des mares notamment la
Martine pour avancer en tout cas sachez
que j tiens particulièrement et vous
avez rappelé à juste titre 80 % de la
biodiversité et dans les territoires
ultrarins et que les corau c'est 15 % et
j'étais en Polynésie j'ai pu voir avec
joie que c'est un organisme de recherche
français lin ser pour pas les citer et
qui était en en capacité de trouver des
solutions pour avancer sur les déchets
c'est un sujet très compliqué dans
beaucoup de sur ultramarin là encore on
peut déplorer qu'il n'y ait pas d'
traitement d'ord ménagur c'est pas vrai
partout je reviens de saint-barteléi il
y a un système
très qui marche très bien avec une
cogénération je peux citer également
Bâton Rouge en à la Réunion il y a la
cogénération très très intéressante mais
d'autres territoires nous sommes dans
une impasse et il faudra avancer David
ran monsieur le
Président alors sur l'inflation vous
m'avez posé une vraie question je vous
fournirai les éléments écrits parce que
je sais que votre question a était
très précise est-ce que non parce quez
parlé d'augmentation du budget
l'inflation si vous a bien écouté est
plus important
territult ça n'est pas ce que j'ai comme
chiffre donc je propose qu'on confronte
nos données et je m'engage vous don
devant président de la commission
surz sur rattrapage oui je cro tout à
fait expliqu làdessus collègue Jean ch
vous avez RA spécifit gu ou c'est la TA
du Portugal
c'est la grande région suakquitaine
c'est sûr que ça n'a rien à voir avec
des territoires plus petits comme
d'autres comme la Martinique par exemple
vous avez cité d'autres territoire et
avec c'est vrai 35 % de population qui
viennent à la fois d'Haïti qui viennent
à la fois du Surinam qui viennent à la
fois du Brésil et une population très
jeune 50 % de la population à moins de
25 ans un problème des fonciers
absolument majeur le niveau des eaux av
reparlé la semaine dernière qui s'est
aggravé d'ailleurs depuis quelques jours
qui fait que maintenant il y a même des
navigations qui ne sont plus possibles
et et vous m'avez parlé d'ailleurs de de
l'achèvement de la route de Marie
passoua il va falloir trouver des
solutions ensemble en tout cas j'ai été
interrogé cette question pas plus tard
que ce matin et l'argument que vous avez
avancé pour moi me paraît pertinent donc
persuadé qu'on pourra ensemble trouver
des solutions mais question vous avez
posé sont frappé dans la pertinence et
vous reconnaîtrez avec moi quand même
qu'on a eu une belle initiative en
Guyane c'est l'école connectée qui
permet à des enfants des collégiant en
l'espèce on a mis 800000 € pour que dans
4 village distant de 2h de de Pirog les
uns des autres et bien les enfants
puissent bénéficier d' enseignement je
pense qu'avec le développement du
numérique et avec d'ailleurs des
enseignants extraordinairement engagés
je crois qu'on a commencé à apporter une
réponse et cette réponse on pu la
multiplier sur le territoire vous
trouverez avec moi quelqu'un qui et bien
vous aidera madame Lenormand vous avez
monsieur Lenormand pardon oh pardon
excusez-moi pardon monsieur le député
Monsieur Le Normand pardon stabilité du
budget c'est vrai vous avez dit que 70
li000 le logements indigne avec des des
problèmes d'insalibrité vous avez
insisté sur ce que nous faisions sur
l'accès à l'eau que ça soit en Guyane
etàs j'ai dit tout à l'heure en
Guadeloupe et et Maillotte mais il
faudra très probablement parler parler
de de la Guyane qu à Saint-Pierre et
mielon je vis quand même vous préciser
une chose peut-être n'avez-vous pas le
chiffre et vous avez reconnu que j'avais
déjà reçu les délégations et vous-même à
plusieurs reprises et et j'irai dans
quelques jours euh jeevendrai vers vous
pour un sujet qui est encore pour le
moment pas arbitré mais sur lequel j'ai
bon espoir d' arriver en revanche je
reviens vers vous vers le avec le CCT
qui va passer de 19 millions à 25
millions donc vous voyez qu'on a une
petite augmentation pluselle minime mais
elle est déjà là le le sujet de l'ancien
hôpital ne m'a pas échappé et suit des
normes parce que je prends toujours
l'exemple des escableau Canadiens qui
n'est m qui ne correspond pas à des
normes ça me permet de dire mesdames
messieurs les députés qu'il va y avoir
un grand rendez-vous c'est le 15 mars
2024 vous savez enfin la la l'adoption
définitive des fameuses normes rupes par
rapport au nomme ce mais ça ne suffira
pas ça sera déjà un élément très
structurant en matière des matériaux
parce que souvent on fait faire 5 8
10000 km 20000 km à des matériaux pour
qu'il soit estampé Union européenne là
les normes RUP nous finissons de porter
au niveau européen l'avancée de cette
norme RUP qui sera quand même quelque
chose attendu depuis tant d'années et
nous allons faire un travail sur la
révision des autres normes hein parce
que chaque ministre a accepté maintenant
que dans les nouvelles lois et bien il y
aura un volet ultra marin là sur les
anciennes normes on a tout ce volet qu'
qu'il faut travailler et bien très
attentif parce ça c'est un facteur de de
discrimination de compétitivité
important voilà madamees Messieurs les
Députés pardonnez-moi peut-être d'avoir
été long et je tenais essayer d'être
plus complé avant de répondre aux autres
questions merci monsieur le ministre je
prexcuser de mon retard il a un retard
de train monsieur le rapporteur vous
aviez un propos et j'ai ensuite une
question de Monsieur Mandon
oui merci monsieur le Président je je
répondrai en deux parties une première
réponse adressée plus à monsieur riman
et une deuxième monsieur le
ministrean si je vous
écoute la Guyenne est grande on est
d'accord les frontières sont longues on
est d'accord et donc nous ne pourrions
rien faire en matière d'immigration et
de contrôle des frontières si je vous
écoute là aujourd'hui il faut accueillir
toujours plus et construire plus de de
logement d'hébergement d'urgence c'est
ce que vous avez dit il y a quelques
minutes alors je suis assez surpris
quand même de de vos propos parce que et
je mais je comprends que vous soyez gêné
ici à la assemblée nationale surtout
vous êtes entouré d'une éminente membre
de la nupes en la personne de Madame
Rousseau que vous soyez euh
embêté pour assumer votre double
discours parce que votre double discours
ici à l'Assemblée et votre discours dans
votre circonscription en guyan est très
différent en guyen vous tenez des propos
qui sont très clairement contre
l'immigration massive vous tenez des
propos pour stopper toute immigration
près de vos électeurs et ici vous nous
dites finalement que ce n'est pas un
problème et d'ailleurs vous dites même
qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre sécurité
et immigration c'est ce que vous avez
dit il y a quelques minutes moi je suis
stupéfait par vos propos parce que vous
tenez un tout autre discours ang guyan
et en plus de cela ça n'a aucun
fondement sécurité immigration sont liés
c'est une évidence euh vous êtes allé
d'ailleurs il y a quelques semaines au
centre pénitentiaire de de Cayenne j'y
suis allé également euh j'ai suis que
vous y étiez allé parce que sur le livre
d'or j'ai vu votre nom juste avant le
mien euh et en visitant ce centre
pénitentiaire vous avez forcément vu la
réalité et vous avez forcément vu que la
moitié des détenus était étranger donc
dire qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre
immigration et insécurité c'est tout
simplement nier la réalité petite
réponse vous concernant monsieur le
ministre je pense que vous préférez vous
aussi nier la réalité mais je pense que
vous la connaissez cette réalité comme
moi vous êtes allé en guyen il y a
quelques semaines comme moi vous avez
rencontré des acteurs du territoire un
petit peu moins que moi mais vous en
avez
rencontré vous avez même modifié
d'ailleurs votre programme de votre
déplacement après avoir connu mon
programme mais je m'en félicite tant
mieux tant mieux n'avez-vous
pas échapper monsieur le ministre au
propos des Guyanais ne vous ont-ils pas
dit ne vous ont-ils pas fait part de
leur sentiment d'être des Français de
seconde zone n'avez-vous pas entendu la
population et les acteurs du territoire
dire nous avons un pays à construire
n'avez-vous pas comme moi traversé de
longues zones blanches allant de
saint-georg
ou à Saint-Laurent n'avez-vous pas
également rencontré des maires qui ont
été contraints pour se déplacer à
Cayenne de venir en pirogue n'avez-vous
pas rencontré des élus locaux qui vous
ont dit qu'ils avaient de grandes
difficultés pour construire des écoles
et qu'il leur fallait comme Madame le
Maire de de Saint-Laurent du Maroni par
exemple devoir construire 20 classes
supplémentaires chaque année alors
certes l'état accompagne financièrement
en partie mais les collectivités
territoriales qui souffrent énormément
financièrement sont-elles obligées de
mettre la main à la poche et c'est
d'autant plus embêtant que quand vous
parlez des sommes que vous mettez en
investissement et de l'effort qui est
fait par l'État vous oubliez que il y a
déjà un un retard à à à rattraper et que
finalement ce que vous investissez
aujourd'hui de manière très
insuffisante ne fait qu'absorber une
partie des infrastructures nécessaires
qui est d notamment à l'augmentation de
la population et qui est dû en grande
partie à l'immigration de masse quant à
Saint-Laurent du Maroni il faut 20
nouvelles classes chaque année à chaque
rentrée c'est en effet en partie du fait
d'une natalité importante en guyan en
général mais aussi et surtout du fait
d'une immigration de masse monsieur le
ministre quand vous êtes déplacé en
guyen n'avez-vous pas vu également que
le coût de la vie est relativement
important on voit des packs d'eau
jusqu'à 15 € par exemple euh
l'alimentation en général c'est plus 42
% par rapport à à la France hexagonale
n'avez-vous pas également traversé la
guyan sur un réseau routier qui est
quasiment inexistant finalement parce
qu'il y a que quelques routes en Guyane
le réseau routier est défoncé et en plus
il est largement
insuffisant vous avez j'imagine monsieur
le ministre dormi également à à Cayenne
à Cayenne j'imagine que vous êtes sorti
après 18h et que vous avez vu une ville
qui est engrainé par l'insécurité avec
énormément d'immigration et ce qu'on
appelle des zombies là-bas parce que ce
sont des gens qui sont totalement sous
craque la situation est intenable le
préfet lui-même m'a dit dès que je suis
arrivé en Guyane monsieur le député vous
verrez l'insécurité finalement c'est pas
c'est pas autant qu'on peut le dire mais
il m'a dit quelques minutes après
monsieur le député évitez de sortir
après 18h quand même ça peut être
dangereux donc il faut un petit peu
redescendre sur terre et être conscient
de ce qui se passe et je pense à
Monsieur le Ministre que vous l'avez vu
forcément vous l'avez vu lors de votre
déplacement vous avez dit que il y avait
plus de magistrats et que de nouveaux
magistrats allaient arriver dans les
prochaines semaines les prochains mois
et tant mieux et on s'en félicite et et
on pourrait presque vous applaudir pour
ça mais avez-vous rencontré le monde
judiciaire en Guyane ne vous ont-ils pas
dit qu'effectivement des magistrats
supplémentaires c'était une bonne chose
mais qu' avait pas assez de greffier et
que sans greffier bah ça peut pas tourné
ne vous ont-ils pas dit également qu'il
n'avait pas de locaux appropriés les
greffiers ne sont pas prévus dans dans
les budgets non et ne vous ont-il pas
dit qu'il n'avait pas de locaux
appropriés et qu'il ne pouvait pas
travailler correctement sans ces locaux
vous avez dit également qu'une prison
allait arrivriver à l'horizon 2027 bah
écoutez j'espère vous croire j'espère
vous croire mais excusez-moi on a du mal
à le croire puisqu'elle avait déjà été
promis pour 2023 et qu'à l'heure
actuelle aucune démarche administrative
n'a encore commencé pour cette fameuse
prison donc on a un peu de mal à croire
qu'elle soit ouverte en 2027 mais si
c'est le cas tant mieux vous avez parlé
des TF qui sont c'est vrai
impressionnante en terme de chiffres en
guyan et on peut pas dire le contraire
et et et et et oui je vous le dis oui
effectivement les résultats des TF sur
le papier sont impressionnantes mais la
réalité c'est quoi la réalité c'est que
ces otf sont CER réalisés mais qu'il y a
aussi beaucoup d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui ne sont pas sousqtf et
que en plus quand bien même leqtf pardon
est exécuté les étrangers en question
reviennent sur le territoire parce que
les frontières ne sont pas surveillé et
pire que ça j'imagine que vous avez
discuté avec des agents de la police aux
frontières qui vous ont dit eux-mêmes
j'imagine comme ils me l'ont dit à moi
qu'ils viennent toquer carrément à la
porte pour que l'qtf soit exécuté
notamment les Brésiliens comme ça ça
leur permet de rentrer au pays
gratuitement à Noël ou lors de la fête
nationale et puis dès que Noël ou la
fête nationale est terminée et bien on
revient en Guyane illégalement voilà
donc je pense monsieur le ministre que
vous n'avez pas
lu mon rapport mais j'espère que vous
aurez l'occasion de le lire je pense
qu'il pourra vous
servir monsieur le ministre si vous
voulez moi j'ai quelques réponse ACI à
apporter parce que on y est on est allé
en Guyane et avant que vous posiez une
question monsieur Mandon d'abord le lien
que vous faites entre immigration et
insécurité il est permanent il est
constant et il est en quelque sorte
infondé puis par que la question des
cartels elle est aujourd'hui
l'instrumentalisation des guyanis des
habitants guyan et les mules qui passent
aujourd'hui de la guyan vers la France
elles sont françaises et donc d'ailleurs
vous avez utilisé un propos que j'ai
trouvé assez assez incohérent vous avez
parlé de pays à construire en parlant de
la Guyane la guyan la Guyane c'est la
France non mais la Guyane c'est la
France Monsieur rapporteur je vous le
rappelle quand même c'est pas parce que
les gens sont différents que ce ne sont
pas des
Français ensite je veux vous dire que
vous avez rapidement absou les
collectivités puisque vous avez parlé
des compétences sur les constructions on
ne peut pas exonérer les respons des
collectivités de leur responsabilité oui
les collectivités ont une part à prendre
pour la construction des écoles oui les
collectivités ont une part à prendre
pour la proposition des terrains pour
les prisons vous savez d'ailleurs que la
conditionnalité des 3000 places
supplémentaires au-delà du plan 15000
sont conditionné aussi aux autorisations
d'urbanisme qui sont délivrés par les
collectivités parce que nous on veut
bien mettre à disposition des crédits on
veut bien donner des autorisations euh
pour le construire mais il faut que les
collectivités nous donnent des permis de
construire et ça pour le coup en guyan
comme ailleurs si on n' pas
d'autorisation il faut il faut un
terrain il faut qu'on nous le donne ben
oui mais pour déposer un permis il faut
un terrain monsieur le député et donc à
partir de là vous ne pouvez pas avoir de
terrain qui soit inventés par l'État
vous parlez avec le Président riman vous
connaîtrez aussi toutes les difficultés
qui sont celles de la propriété foncière
en Guyane et notamment de son
remembrement ensuite vous avez parlé
d'absorption euh de d'une immigration de
masse alors il est vrai et ça personne
ne le réfute qu' guyan en particulier il
y a une immigration de masse pourquoi
parce que vous avez fait vous-même le
constat de frontières qui sont
incontrôlables expliquez comment votre
parti contrôlerait des frontières qui
représente la taille d'un pays du
Portugal au cœur de la for amazonienne
expliquez comment sur le Maroni vous
parviendrez à arrêter totalement
l'immigration illégale Enan c'est
impossible y compris même pendant le
confinement lorsque le préfet Marc grand
D était était en attends mais attendez
madame Roulot je crois pas vous avoir
interrompu donc vous m'écoutez comme
tout le monde d'accord ensuite le préfet
Marc del grande quand il était en Guyane
pour le covid je vous rappelle que il a
pris des dispositions particulières
parce que précisément les frontières
étaient incontrôlables notamment avec le
Surinam
oui alors je pense que pour ce qui
concerne les crédits de toutes les
missions immigration et asile on vous a
montré
dans les budgets qui ont été votés
examinés préalablement qui sont en
augmentation et considérable parler
également d'un territoire gangriné par
l'insécurité oui c'est pour ça que on
dispose aujourd'hui d'un renforcement
des forces de l'ordre qui s'agisse du
gignn qui s'agisse de CRS qui s'agisse
de forces spécialisées qui sont
déployées sur le territoire et
d'ailleurs à la demande du préfet à la
demande du préfet ben oui parce que il y
a des escadrons qui sont aussi
redéployés je pense qu'il y a des
questions aussi de sécurité qui à
Mayotte nécessiteent le déploiement qui
en Nouvelle-Calédonie nécessite aussi
l'intervention et donc effectivement
nous avons créé des forces de police
mais je vois que vous considérz qu'il en
manqué ça tombe bien puisque 8500 sont
prévus sous ce quinquen également vous
évoquez également les questions des
magistrats alors sur les magistrat non
seulement on a des affectations
nouvelles on a des greffiers nouveaux
mais on a aussi mis en place certaines
dispositions je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez sur la loi justice on avait
permis notamment auprès de la GES donc
la juridiction interrégionale et
spécialisée de pouvoir avoir une
utilisation de la vidéo de la vidéo pour
la vidéo audience pour qu'on évite de
faire des transférements de prévenus
depuis la Guyane vers la Martinique pour
qu'on additionne ces personnes à for-
de-fance et qu'on les renvoie ensuite
tout ça c'est des dispositions qui
permettent d'accélérer les procédures de
d'éviter le transfert mon détenu
d'éviter de le surcharge de travail de
l'administration pénitentiaire et par
ailleurs de mieux faire fonctionner les
services publics non mais monsieur
monsieur rapporteur je ve bien que vous
soyez vous soyez aujourd'hui un peu
ironique mais la réalité que vous
décrivez c'est que vous vous vous
décrivez une situation du tier monde
dans lequel l'État investit énormément
au profit des populations qui par
ailleurs savent la difficulté que nous
avons à déployer des services publics
qui savent la difficulté à construire
des infrastructures et qui vivent une
réalité c bien moins noir que celle que
vous venez de le faire et de venez la
présenter Monsieur Emmanuel Mandon pour
une question je vous remercie monsieur
le Président en complément donc
l'intervention de mon collègue Franz
gums qui a souhaité S souligner avec
beaucoup de conviction les besoins de
son territoire je voudrais revenir sur
la mobilité j'observe que la mobilité
telle qu'elle est prévu dans ce budget
concerne les déplacements entre l'outrem
et l'Hexagone bien souvent cependant il
y a à saint-bartelémie par exemple des
apprentis et pas suffisamment
d'entreprises pour les accueillir et
leur offrir un contrat donc
l'apprentissage n'est ici possible que
dans le cadre de la mobilité ce qui
signifie qu'un certain nombre d'entre
eux doivent se rendre en Guadeloupe
peut-on envisager la prise en entre les
îles d'un même bassin d'une même zone
géographique c'està-dire ici de
saint-barthelémie à la Guadeloupe ou la
Martinique par exemple nous savons que
vous déployez monsieur le ministre de
vrais efforts pour apporter des réponses
concrètes et que vous avez à cœur de
donner des perspectives à la jeunesse
ultramarine donc je vous remercie pour
vos éléments de
réponse alors Monsieur le Ministre
voulais ajouter dernier mot ou dernier
mot si m'autorisez monsieur le Président
mais dans votre intervention vous vous
avez beaucoup de force
argument des choses que j'avais déjà dit
dans mon intervention liminire d'abord
je vrais dire au rapporteur général que
je n'ai pas pour habitude de Cal mes
déplacements en fonction du passage des
parlementaires la deuxième chose que je
voulais vous dire c'est que votre
rapport je l'ai lu parce que la moine
des courtoisies lorsque les
parlementaires font des rapports voyez
c'est de les lire et donc même si je
l'ai eu tardivement je l'ai lu et c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs vous
avez souligné 10 points et comme vous
avez bien écouté ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure il y a au moins déjà
quatre qui sont satisfaits oui mais vous
dites non parce que de toute façon ça
sera jamais assez on a bien compris que
l'original est toujours supérieur à la
copie mais en tout cas moi ce que je
peux vous dire nousons contesté que des
moyens considérables ont été mis en
place le président lorsqu'il vous dit
connaissez la Guyane il se trouve que
comme j'ai quelques cheveux blancs de
plus que vous je la connais depuis plus
longtemps que vous la Guyane est un très
grand pays et franchement d'expliquer
qu'on va contrôler chaque mtre ça c'est
pas vrai vous racontez des choses qui ne
sont pas crédibles une seule seconde on
a déployer des moyens considérables ces
moyens considérables il faut aller plus
loin mais c'est je pense pas que nous
soyons sur une trajectoire inverse force
de reconnaître et puis il y a une fois
de plus il y aura une VO sur
l'immigration on verra quelles sont les
responsabilités que vous prenez lorsque
ce texte viendra devant l'Assemblée
nationale je vis dire sur les actions de
coopération avec les pays voisins jamais
autant d'initiatives avaient été prises
j'ai d'ailleurs même rencontré à titre
personnel le et a du ministère
l'ambassadeur du Brésil parce que bien
sûr qu'il faut trouver des accords avec
les pays qui nous entourent et vous
savez combien les choses sont faciles
personne n'a paré de leur paillage vous
avez vu les moyens là encore considérabl
qu'on a déployé sur leur paillage qui
est encore tellement trop important 5
fois supérieur à la rcherche d'orifèire
normale pour autant le chemin parcouru a
déjà été sensiblement important depuis
quelques années il fallait le dire on a
par exemple voyez sur les dispositions
particulières pour pas être trop long
monsieur le Président en matière de
droits étrangers les réductions du
droits d'examens ont été fait pour les
demandes d'asile c'est raison pour
laquelle je permis de vous citer tous
les chiffres qui permettent de montrer
nos interventions massives tant en
matière judiciaire qu'en matière
policière et je vous ai rappelé les
programmes que l'on a construire avec la
pig donc pour le ministère de la Justice
sa laurend du Maroni je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure 2027 c'est très long si un jour
vous êtes maire vous verrez que pour
bâti une structure de 200 millions
d'euros ça ne se fait pas en 12 mois il
y a des codes de marché public il y a
des procédures engagées il y a des
analyses d'Off à faire il y a il y a le
délai de la construction et vous verrez
que ce que l'on pense faire en pouvoir
une année ça vous fait sourire mais
croyez-moi mon expérience et si vous
doutez virez voir je vous ai pas
interrompu donc il y a la même
courtoisie et vous verrez mon expérience
et vous verrez que pour que pour bâtir
on arrive à faire un C nombre de choses
mais qui demande quand même un certain
nombre de délis et ces délais par moment
sont incompréensibles je rappelle à tout
le monde ce sera mon dernier mot pour
vous répondre monsieur le rapporteur
qu'à Saint-Laurent duaroni outre le
centre pénitentiaire un tribunal
judiciaire un SPIP et unité éducative de
milieux ouvert et enfin la mer de
Saint-Laurent du Maroni puisque vous
avez fait référence je l'ai rencontré
naturellement elle était même très
heureux dans le propos qu'elle a
prononcé puisque je suis arrivé pas avec
rien avec 120 millions d'euros pour
construire les vs écoles c'est me
semble-t-il une belle contribution qui
permet je crois d'apporter une réponse
même si c'est vrai les Vécole je ne
conteste pas de chiffre mais on ne peut
pas contester qu'il y ait pas un effort
financier particulier qui a été fait
pour aider Saint-Laurent du Maroni elle
l'a reconnu publiciquement et la presse
sera là pour le confirmer enfin tout à
l'heure le députés Mandon de la Loire m
thoger sur ce sujet de de continuité
territoriale et naturellement du coûte
euh lorsque nous sommes à
saint-barttinis à Saint-Martin pour
rejoindre c'est vrai c'est une question
qui se pose à tout instant j'ai expliqué
monsieur le député juste avant que vous
n'arrivier que il fallait que on revoit
comment toutes ces dessertes sorganis
j'ai les mêmes difficultés avec
Saint-Pierre et miclon j'ai les mêmes
difficultés avecalcé Futuna avec des DSP
qui coûtent beaucoup d'argent pas
toujours le bon remplissage enfin bref
avec le cabinet et le cabinet de
clémentb nous sommes en train de
travailler sur un nouveau cier des
charges qui permettra je l'espère
d'apporter une meilleure réponse parce
que ces habitants de ce territoire
méritent une uité territoriale
desarifications plus abordbl que c qu'on
le propose voilà monsieur le Président
j'espère avoir été à pe près complet les
commission je remerci la discussion
générale on va suspendreagner ministre
commencer
lesend oigation et je rejoind d'ici un
quart d'heure merci beaucoup